[Musique]
vous êtes sur public sénat bonjour à
tous ce qu'est ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
qu'est ce qui peut être doit être même
améliorée notamment au niveau
administratif c'est l'objet de la
commission denquête mise en place cet
été par le sénat cet après midi ce sont
les syndicats d' internes des hôpitaux
qui sont entendues hors garde l'audition
on en reparle juste après lyon qui ont
fait 6 ans de médecine et qui sont
désormais à temps plein à l'hôpital pour
prendre en charge les patients jusqu'à
la fin de leur internat et l'obtention
de leur diplôme d'enseignement supérieur
[Musique]
pendant pendant cette crise pendant
cette crise sanitaire les internes ont
été ont été en première ligne
ils représentent 25 % des médecins
hospitaliers et 40 % des médecins dans
les chu est habituellement les internes
sont indispensables au fonctionnement
des hôpitaux
c'est important pour moi de revenir sur
le contexte dans lequel cette crise
sanitaire est arrivé quand quand a
commencé la crise sanitaire nous avons
mis fin le 19 février une grève
historique qui a duré 70 jours dans
laquelle nous nous sommes fortement
mobilisés contre les manques de moyens
et de personnel je tiens à signaler que
pendant ces soixante dix jours de grève
qui a été massivement suivi
aucune de nos revendications notamment
sur les questions du temps de travail et
des situations d'épuisement
professionnel que nous avons que nous
avons fait remonter ont été entendus
nous avons fait en 2019 une enquête qui
a retrouvé un temps hebdomadairement et
moyens de travail qui était de l'ordre
de 50 6 heures est ce que nous demandons
c'est que la réglementation française
permettent un décompte horaire du temps
de travail des internes pour ne plus
dépasser la réglementation européenne
qui est de l'ordre de 48 heures là
dessus nous avons eu un heureux
fut à l'époque de madame la ministre
agnès buzyn début depuis début 2000
vingt quand a commencé la crise
sanitaire
il y avait déjà quatre internes qui
s'était suicidé notamment à cause
d'épuisement professionnel
je vous passe les chiffres sur le sur le
sur la santé mentale des internes en
france mais elle est catastrophique et
les situations d'épuisement sont
nombreuses c'est donc dans ce contexte
qui est arrivée la crise sanitaire
est ce que je dois ce que je dois dire
tout d'abord c'est que dans nos rapports
avec les instances nationales qui sont
d'habitude assez d'assez bonne qualité
avec des réunions bi hebdomadaire nous
discutons avec les conseillers des
cabinets notre interlocuteur est le
directeur de cabinet et bien là il ya eu
un retard à l'allumage puisque nous
avons écrit un courrier le 19 février
pour être reçu par les cabinets et ce
n'est que le 19 mars que nous avons
enfin eu une réponse et une proposition
de rendez vous donc ce qui s'est passé
un mois un mois de latence pendant
lesquels nous n'avons eu ni consigne ni
initiative des différentes
administrations pour nous permettre
notamment de réaffecter les internes là
où il ya là où il y en avait besoin
nous avons donc décidé de prendre
l'initiative de ces réaffectations afin
de placer les internes des services qui
étaient les moins surchargées dans les
services où il y avait besoin d'eux
c'est à dire les recenser faire état de
leurs compétences pour pouvoir les
replacer nous avons aussi réalisé un
appel à la mobilisation générale des
internes pour faire revenir tous ceux
qui étaient en vacances en disponibilité
en année recherche et qu'ils puissent
prendre leurs fonctions
je dois dire que là dedans les
administrations étaient particulièrement
absente
nous avons dû créer nos propres cellules
de crise pour l'organiser comme la
cellule de crise de de l'île de france
dont julien pour parler plus amplement
pour organiser toutes ces réaffectations
l'important pour nous était avant tout
qu'il n'y ait pas pendant cette crise
sanitaire de suicide d'un interne par
épuisement professionnel
nous avons érigé le droit au
remplacement permettre à l'internaute
d'être remplacé par un collègue quand il
sentait que la charge de travail était
trop importante
nous avons nous avons fini par écrire un
courrier cosigné par la conférence des
doyens de santé la conférence des dg de
chu la conférence des présidents de cme
pour obtenir des mesures réglementaires
qui était qui était nécessaire pour
pouvoir procéder à ces réaffectations
plusieurs mesures étaient nécessaires et
ce n'est qu'à la suite de ce courrier
que nous avons finalement obtenu une
instruction des cabinets puis de des
rendez vous avec hebdomadaire avec les
cabinets permettant de faire d'appliquer
au mieux la réglementation et de mettre
en place des guides à destination des rs
et des centres hospitaliers pour
améliorer les conditions
parmi ces mesures une mesure qui a été
pour nous très importante
ça a été de repousser la fin de semestre
moment les internautes à terminent tous
au 1er mai et il était clair que dans le
contexte actuel on ne pouvait pas
désorganiser l'ensemble des services et
se priver d'une bonne partie des
internes actuellement en fonction nous
avons donc demandé à ce que la fin de
semaine sera repoussée d'un mois ce qui
a permis aussi de conserver des médecins
au sein de l'hôpital public
parmi parmi les faits qui ont été qui
ont été marquants nous avons réalisé
plusieurs plusieurs enquêtes et je dois
dire que les conclusions que qu'on en a
tiré son sont graves
c'est à dire que sur notre enquête nous
avons interrogé 981 terme
les deux tiers d'entre nous disent ne
pas avoir pu accéder à du matériel de
protection en quantité suffisante
on parle là de deux masques de sur blues
on a eu que la moitié des internes 53%
qui présentaient des symptômes ducobu
début de la crise qui ont pu accéder à
des tests de dépistage
c'est à dire que la plupart des internes
n'ont pas pu connaître leur statut et on
sait aujourd'hui que plus d'un interne
sur deux qui connaissait son diagnostic
étant positive vocaux vide a été obligé
de travailler malgré sa positivité
donc c'est à dire qu'il a mis en danger
des collègues à lui et qu'il a aussi
bien entendu mis en danger des patients
nous savons que les soignants et
particulièrement les internes sont une
source de contamination pour les
patients pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont dû
travailler parce que les politiques de
gestion des ressources humaines des
hôpitaux notamment à destination des
internes sont de très mauvaise qualité
la durée moyenne des arrêts maladie a
été de 8 jours il ya eu aucun contrôle
aucune surveillance et surtout le
personnel étaient manquants on ne
pouvait pas dans les services se mettre
en arrêt maladie et arrêter de soigner
les patients
je tiens à rajouter que 5% des internats
infectées ont présenté une forme sévère
de la maladie
heureusement nous n'avons pas eu à
déplorer la perte d'un interne mais un
certain nombre a été hospitalisé pour
cette maladie
je tiens aussi à souligner qu'il n'ya
pas eu de priorisation pour le
rapatriement des personnels soignants et
des internes à l'étranger et qu'on nous
a renvoyé vers le ministère des affaires
étrangères sans aucune sans aucune aide
pour rapatrier des forces sur le
territoire je pense que les dix minutes
sont son passé je laisse la parole âge
merci beaucoup
alors monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
du coup je m'appelle juillet en folio je
suis président du syndicat des internes
des hôpitaux de paris
les jeux représentent les internes de
l'interrégion ile de france qui est une
région assez dense en ce qui concerne
les internes puisqu'un interne sur six
en france est affecté en ile-de-france à
l'ap-hp on est six mille interne en
ile-de-france comme tu le disais juste
un dès le 16 mars en fait à l'instar de
nos collègues interne de la région grand
est
on a proposé à la range à l'agencé
régionale de santé de s'organiser
nous-mêmes pour récolter toutes les tous
les noms des internes ou volontaires
pourraient les aider dans les services
qui étaient en difficulté
on a eu des réponses d'abord de la
conférence des doyens d'île de france
puis de la rs et de l'ap-hp
donc on a dû se mettre en accord avec
leur plan organisationnel qui nous
imposait de déclarer chaque interne qui
changeait d'hôpital ou de service à son
coordonnateur donc qui est le
responsable de son diplôme mais
également à son doyen à son chef de
service à la rs est ainsi qu à l ap hp
qui est son chu de rattachement et
également pour la gestion du coût de ces
internes
on a recruté 31 interne qui était dédiée
à temps plein à la gestion également des
retours des services qui avait besoin de
médecins c'est principalement grâce à
des situations particulières qu'on
aurait pu recruter des internes qui
pouvaient travailler à temps plein sur
cette problématique puisque c'était
principalement des internes qui étaient
en situation de grossesse donc il devait
être en éviction des services ou bien
également des internes qui avaient qui
ont des pathologies chroniques et qui
devait également être en éviction donc
c'est 31 internes ont pu rassembler un
réseau de 250 interne à travers les
hôpitaux d'île de france où on avait
chaque on avait des données quotidiennes
sur la situation tendue en médecins et
en interne de chaque service de
réanimation d'urgence et
d'hospitalisation covit d'île de france
chaque jour une remontée le besoin de
médecins ce qu'on a pu faire du coup
c'est récolter les données et les noms
et les contacts des internes qui étaient
volontaires pour participer à l'offre de
soins et au soutien à ces services qui
étaient en difficulté dès le 16 mars
on a lancé un questionnaire en ligne
pour récolter le nom des internes ou
volontaire en tout sur deux mois on a pu
récolter 1900 interne franciliens qui
souhaitait aider les internautes qui
souhaitait aider les services en
difficultés dont 1200 dans les 48
premières heures et nous avons pu
participer à près de 600 transfert
dans les services en difficultés en ile
de france à côté de ça comme comme tu
disais juste un on a également eu besoin
de soutenir les internes qui était en
difficulté parce que notre syndicat une
cellule spécifique de soutien psychique
et morale parce que les internats des
risques psychosociaux bien spécifiques
comme comme tu le disais précédemment on
l'intersyndicale nationale des internes
avaient déjà pu faire des des enquêtes
sur la santé mentale des internes qui
relevait déjà deux tiers 2 internes qui
ont des symptômes anxieux
un tiers des symptômes dépressifs et un
choeur qui ont des idées suicidaires
dans le dernier mois
liste ni a également pu faire une
enquête santé mentale suite à la crise
qu vide et tous ces chiffres ont été
revus à la hausse et donc on sait
organiser nous-mêmes pour avoir pour
augmenter en tout cas notre ambras notre
cellule de soutien psychologique au sein
du syndicat des internes des hôpitaux de
paris
en ce qui concerne également la gestion
des internes du coup à travers l'île de
france et que on est répartie
habituellement dans près de 180 hôpitaux
partout en ile de france que ce soit
dans l'intra muros ou dans les
départements de la grande couronne et
notre but vraiment c'était de répartir
les internes dans tous les hôpitaux y
compris les hôpitaux qui sont déjà en
difficulté habituellement je pense par
exemple à l'hôpital de longjumeau qui
est déjà en difficulté habituellement
qui en manque de médecins notre volonté
c'était vraiment de répartir l'offre de
soins sur l'ensemble des territoires
français
on a dû du coup accompagner les internes
qui était en difficulté ne serait ce que
pour se loger à proximité ces hôpitaux
ou de se déplacer dans ces hôpitaux
parce que quand on sort d'une guerre de
réanimation ou une garde aux urgences ou
d'une journée qui traîne et on termine à
21h à meaux c'est difficile de rentrer
quand les transports en commun sont
réduits du fait de la crise sanitaire
du coup on s'est arrangé également avec
cette cellule de crise pour obtenir des
logements et des facilités de transport
pour l'ensemble des internes qui étaient
affectés dans des hôpitaux périphériques
avec un grand soutien de la région ile
de france qui nous a également aidés
avec une conciergerie entièrement
gratuite pour les internes francilien
avec des voitures mises à disposition et
des logements y compris des logements
crous voilà c'est merci beaucoup merci à
vous même de roche notre rapporte
heureux
c'est un tous les deux de des précisions
vous ne nous donnez sur le rôle et la
situation d un terme au monde au moment
de la crise lorsque vous évoquez
solution un peu d'organisation qui vous
a été propre pour pour mettre en place
ce réseau des internes
quel a été le soutien vous avez parlé de
la région ile-de-france qui vous
apporter un soutien quel a été le
soutien la rs dans cette gestion le
deuxième point c'est vous décrivez une
situation de difficulté psychologique
des internes même parfois même avant la
dcri chez les étudiants en santé
est ce que cette gestion de crise au
moment de la première vague a accentué
ses difficultés si vous avez des d
analyse comment comment vous êtes
soutenus sur ce plan là et par rapport à
la situation des internes qui sont en
formation puisque vous avez des vous
fait des études en même temps qu'eux
enfin des études dans le cadre de cette
fonction d'un thème quel est l'impact
sur des études dans des spécialités par
exemple que vous notez par rapport à des
des internes qui on est obligé de enfin
qu'ils ont été contraints de rester sur
sur des services qu'ovide par rapport
aux stages qu'il devait faire dans
d'autres services assez pour cette
première partie est ma deuxième question
elle porte sur la situation actuelle
comment vous voyez dans l'est
et les services sur lesquels vous êtes
vous-même ou vos collègues comment ça se
passe qu'est la situation actuelle
puisqu'on en est maintenant à un stade
de couvre feu pour pouvoir essayer
d'enrayer la d'enrayer le nombre
d'hospitalisations essentiellement n'a
dans des services kim qui sont tendues
enfin qui risquent de l'être et surtout
des services avec aussi des lits qui
sont opérationnels manque de personnel
quel est votre avis sur cette mesure
merci bien mes yeux merci monsieur
président alors n'étant pas médecin
bon je vous entends beaucoup d'attention
et je suis assez effaré de vous entendre
bien sûr nous avons procédé à beaucoup
d'auditions déjà avec cette commission
denquête mais un moment donné on nous a
dit que les freins administratifs et
financiers avaient été levées et que par
exemple on avait pu ouvrir des unités
des lits de réanimation en trois jours
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi
compliqué de déplacer des internes d'un
service à un autre ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'épate
on a bien entendu des praticiens nous
dira qu' il y avait plus de frein à un
moment donné on sait que financièrement
effectivement il y en avait plus et sans
doute administrativement non plus
puisque quand il faut ouvrir des unités
il faut parfois trois ans pour arriver à
le faire et là en trois jours on pouvait
le faire mais mais ce qu'on pouvait
faire en trois jours sur des aspects
techniques des aspects d'équipement au
niveau des ressources humaines on
pouvait toujours pas le faire est ce que
c'est ça que vous nous expliquer
déplacer un interne d'un service à un
autre vous pouvez toujours pas le faire
pendant la crise grecque vous me
confirmer cet aspect et est donc en
quelque sorte
ce que n'a pas fait la rs et
particulièrement en ile de france parce
que au travers de nos éditions
on a carrément eu l'impression que s'il
ya un endroit où ça s'était bien passé
entre les élus l'état et puis
et puis
les praticiens c'est en ile de france
alors voilà je voudrais des précisions
sur sur ces aspects là et est-ce que du
coup c'est ces complications au niveau
des ressources humaines
ce que vous pouvez nous dire si ça ne
concerne que les internes ou si ça a
concerné tout le personnel merci je vous
laisse répondre à toutes ces questions
dans la mesure des bouts de vos
possibilités
je vais essayer de répondre au mieux si
j'ai si jamais j'ai oublié quelques
questions n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à
me redire ce que je commence par votre
question parce que c'est la plus fraîche
en interne il a affecté dans un service
réglementairement pour qu'ils changent
de service jusque là c'était c'était pas
possible non la réglementation faut bien
voir qu'un interne c'est un médecin
prescripteur et cantiques anti prescrit
c'est par délégation du chef de service
de son chef de service quand il prescrit
il met sa responsabilité pénale en jeu
et il peut être accusé pénalement
d'homicide involontaire déjà eu
plusieurs cas donc nous on avait besoin
d'un support réglementaire pour faire
cesser réaffectation or ce que ce que
j'expliquais ci qui a eu il ya eu un
délai vraiment une sorte de sidération
pendant laquelle on n'a pas pu obtenir
ce support réglementaire on la demandait
tôt on l'a obtenu le 18 mars
c'est à dire que jusqu'au 18 mars on a
fait des réaffectations mais on mettait
en danger la responsabilité pénale de
nos mandants donc ça c'était ça c'était
la première raison la deuxième j'ai
peut-être plus laisser julien en parler
pour pour la pratique de la mise en
place d'une réaffectation comment ça se
passe et comment ça se passe avec les
interlocuteurs pour l'île de france
et puis j'apporterai peut-être des
compléments de réponse pour les autres
pour les autres régions
en ce qui concerne le plus nos relations
avec les instituts les institutions que
ce soit l'agente régionale de santé ou
ou l'ap-hp keynote chu de rattachement
ça a été également ça ça a été un peu on
a envoyé une solution clé en main
vraiment à l'agencé régionale de santé
parce que ce qui est vraiment difficile
c'est qu'en fait on avait besoin de
compétences dans les services sauf que
les institutions très ont beaucoup de
mal à connaître quel médecin qu'elle
interne à quelles compétences alors oui
il ya les internes
d'anesthésie-réanimation et les internes
d'un intensiviste qui eux c'est écrit
dans leur diplôme s'affairent des
réanimations mais en fait ils tous les
autres un internaute cardiologie ça
passe en réanimation à l'interné pato
qu'être entérologie ça passe en
réanimation ça c'est aussi faire de la
réanimation où il faut qu'il soit
encadré mais sa vie mais il sait en
faire et ça que ce soit le chu que ce
soit les coordonnateurs où que ce soit
la rs
elles ne savent pas qui sont ces
internats également les certaine qu'ils
passent aux urgences on est la majorité
de l'immense majorité des spécialités
passe aux urgences et faits des gardes
aux urgences la rs ne sait pas qui sont
ces internes qui ont des capacités de
pouvoir gérer des urgences nous du coup
qui enfin qui sait de mieux que quelques
compétences sur les intéressés des
internautes même et donc on a demandé
aux internes qui avaient des compétences
de réanimation qui avaient des
compétences d'urgence et on les a
dispatché grâce à ça c'était pas
compliqué du tout de pouvoir changer des
internes de services dans les hôpitaux
parce que comme tu le disais en fait en
interne c'est financé par l'agencé josé
de santé
il ya des sous qui sont donnés à
l'hôpital tous les mois pour qu'ils
payent leur interne en fonction de leur
répartition dans les différents services
et de l'ancienneté ce qui pose est
absolument pas de problème s'était
échangé un interne de service quand
c'était dans le même hôpital
parce qu'en fait c'est le même hôpital
qui payent ce qui a été très compliqué
c'était de changer
l'internet d'hôpital donc on a dû mettre
en place un système de validation avec
les directions des affaires médicales
des hôpitaux
les coordonnateurs l'agencé régionale de
santé mettre tous ces gens d'avoir la
boucle pour chaque interne qui changeait
d'hôpital donc vous imaginez été
relativement dense pendant un certain
moment et en fait qui a créé le plus de
problème à mon sens c'est que la dg os a
mis en place des faq pour aider au mieux
les acteurs du terrain dans la gestion
des étudiants en santé et des internes
ce qui a été le plus problématique à mon
sens oui pardon ce qui est ce qui a créé
le plus de problèmes administrativement
c'est qu'en fait elle ne tranchait pas
sûr qu'ils devaient payer un interne un
interne il est affecté dans un hôpital
pour six mois habituellement donc
l'hôpital dans lequel il est affecté
reçoit des sous pendant six mois pour le
rémunérer sont internes sauf que là on
devait le changer d'hôpital au milieu
sauf qu'en fait son ancien hôpital
continuer à toucher les sous et le
nouvel hôpital dans lequel ils étaient
réaffectées ne touchez pas de sous pour
le payer et moi je me suis retrouvé en
situation en gestion vraiment où aucun
des deux hôpitaux ne voulait payer
l'intérêt parce que il n'est plus chez
moi
oui mais il vient pas de chez moi là
jusqu'au mois d'août que j'ai géré avec
des directions des affaires médicales de
tous les hôpitaux d'ile-de-france des
internes qui n'ont pas été payés pendant
deux mois
donc là et ces internats ils me l'ont
déjà dit ils me l'ont dit d'office s'il
ya une deuxième vague je ne viendrai pas
aidé parce que je n'ai pas été payé par
rapport aux questions du coup que vous
avez pu soulever de santé mentale du
cool
il y avait déjà des risques
psychosociaux vraiment très particulier
sur les internés à une psychopathologie
déjà de fonds relativement importante et
en fait les enquêtes qui a été fait
suite à la crise qu bid a montré qu'il y
avait eu une aggravation de l'ensemble
des symptômes que ce soit d'anxiété ou
de dépression mais également avec
accompagné tine de symptomatologie
traumatique et nos structures de soutien
en fait psychique et moral aux internes
bon on avait triplé les effectifs pour
qu' il puisse les soutenir et également
à ce qu'on puisse les réorienter parce
que du coup ils ont besoin d'être
orienté soir auprès de psychiatre auprès
des psychologues
les internes qui ont téléphoné ne serait
ce que pour avoir un soutien psy chic et
ça a également explosé
on avait vraiment besoin de monde
l'impact sur la formation du coût de
cette crise sanitaire pour les médecins
ça a été multiples là vous avez pu en
parler beaucoup hier lors de la
commission de avec les investisseurs et
animateur c'est qu'en fait les blocs
chirurgicaux ont été fermés toutes les
opérations non urgentes ont été annulés
bah oui mais sauf que l'on a des
internes de chirurgie informés et eux
ont été envoyés dans les réanimations
pour retourner les malades et faire ce
qu'il pouvait dans les services de
médecine ou d'urgence et donc du coup en
fait on arrive là avec des centaines de
chirurgie qui sont moins bien formés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait de blocs
pendant trois quatre cinq mois souvent
pour des du coup en ile-de-france avec
des terrains de stage de très
spécifiques et ultraspécialisés pour
lequel même des internautes région
viennent pour se former
du coup là il ya un manque de formation
pendant plusieurs mois
et également du coup les internes qui se
formaient à la recherche parce que du
coup on avait énormément en interne qui
était en laboratoire tous les
laboratoires ont été fermés donc bon moi
ma situation particulière c'est que
j'étais en laboratoire mais d' analyses
statistiques dont je pouvais faire ça
depuis chez moi mais par contre pour
tous les internes qui était en
laboratoire de recherche et qu'il devait
manipuler toit était fermé
donc beaucoup d'intérêt n'ont pas été
formés à la recherche comme il l'était
habituellement pas avant si je peux je
suis un peut compléter les ce que ce que
ce que julien dit sur la partie sur la
partie financement des internes
il ya la moitié du financement des
postes d'un terne qui sont versées par
les ars sur ce qu'on appelle les
enveloppes mairie qui sont d une sous
enveloppe de l'ondam et l'autre moitié
qui est financé par l'hôpital lui-même
c'est-à-dire globalement sur de là sur
la t2a sur la tarification à l'activité
c'est cette partie je pense t2a qui a
entraîné ces conflits entre les
différents hôpitaux et le fait que le
ministère de la santé
malgré nos demandes répétées émis un tel
temps à trancher sur qui devait être le
payeur non voulais que ce soit
l'établissement d'origine qu'ils soient
meilleurs dans tous les cas mais on voit
que les vieilles logiques budgétaire
tout simplement on continue et on
continuer à fonctionner ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a milité pendant le ségur de la
santé ce qu'on a obtenu sur un
engagement d'accord c'est que les
internes ne soient plus payés par de la
t2a mais uniquement sur des enveloppes
mairie en disant bien que la formation
des médecins ne doit pas passer sur de
la tarification à l'activité en gros de
la rentabilité qui permet de payer la
formation des médecins que ça n'avait
aucun sens maintenant on espère que ces
travaux iront le plus vite possible
parce que c'est juste un engagement de
commencer ses travaux il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de délais qui sont qui sont
mentionnés là dedans sur la partie sur
le sur le l'asb et l'aspect
psychologique qui ce qui est important
de comprendre aussi c'est que les
internes c'est vraiment des gens qui
sont globalement
leur priorité c'est leur formation ils
sont très dévoués aux soins du patient
est en tête on a eu beaucoup de
témoignages d'un terne qui nous faisait
part de situations d'anxiété mais pas
tant au final la peur de la maladie ou
de ne pas savoir prendre en charge les
patients mais surtout la peur de se
retrouver dans une situation où vous
êtes aux urgences un service que vous ne
connaissez pas vous n'avez pas accès à
du matériel de protection
vous avez peur de vous contaminer de
contaminer autres de contaminer votre
famille quand vous rentrez donc c'est un
sentiment à la fois de peur et de colère
entremêlées et eva est vraiment la
détresse psychologique et qui en est né
et ai été intense et on a vraiment des
situations de stress post traumatique
qui conte était qu'on était fréquemment
retrouvées sur la partie de là sur la
partie de la formation
je pense que tous les internes toute la
formation enfin la formation tous les
internes a été impactée dans cette
période qu vite parce que tout le monde
s'est retrouvé déplacer en quelque sorte
à faire une autre tâche qui n'est pas
celle pour lequel il est il est en train
de se former et plus spécifiquement sur
sur la partie de la formation des
internes à la prise en charge du co vide
on a 46 % des internes qui ont déclaré
avoir une mauvaise formation à la
prévention du risque de contamination et
à la prise en charge des patients
pendant la crise qu'ovide 60% des
internes se sont formés eux mêmes et
n'ont pas eu de non pas eu de formation
dispensée par leur établissement
nous on a mis en place une plate forme
de formation numérique pour pallier à ce
manque
mais voilà la qualité aussi de la
formation en temps de crise n'a pas été
au rendez vous
merci je vais passer la parole à même
cohen merci monsieur le président et
merci messieurs pour pour vous éléments
dans le débat qui sont extrêmement
instructif et en même temps effrayant
parce que vous vous dites les choses
avec beaucoup de sincérité sans détour
et c'est important pour notre notre
commission notre commission enquête
moi j'ai trois questions à vous poser de
manière plus précise continue donc de ce
que vous nous avez décrit comme
conditions d'exercice de votre activité
extrêmement extrêmement difficile est-ce
que vous avez aujourd'hui à votre
connaissance le fait que des internes
aurait ou a abandonné finalement le
métier pour lequel il s'était destinée
puisque ça peut aussi avoir
malheureusement assez conséquent cela
donc est-ce que vous avez des éléments
là dessus ma deuxième ma deuxième
question c'est que il est quand même
beaucoup question d'un manque de deux
médecins il ya un numerus clausus qui
est censé avoir été abandonné mais on
sait pertinemment qu'il ne l'est pas
puisque il n'y a pas plus de moyens qui
sont donnés à l'université pour former
plus de médecins donc voilà c'est
simplement enfin pour moi le ministère
qui s'est défaussé mais il n'y a pas
d'actes concrets comment vous évaluez
finalement ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
effectivement avoir plus de médecins
formés 3e troisième question c'est
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
dans la gestion de la crise avec donc là
cette deuxième vague je sais pas si on
peut dire deuxième bague d'ailleurs mais
enfin je veux dire deuxième vague qui
arrive est ce que vous avez le sentiment
des leçons ont été tirées et notamment
par rapport justement à la façon dont on
a maltraité les internes
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
y à une amélioration que des leçons ont
été tirées et que vous avez été quelque
peu
entendue et une question subsidiaire je
suis pas sûr d'avoir bien bien entendu
pardonnez moi de vous faire répéter
pendant l'attendant la pandémie donc au
printemps vous avez au combien d'heures
en moyenne finalement vous avez
travaillé sachant que il me semble que
la durée légale ces 48 heures donc je
pense que vous avez largement dépassé
cette durée mais bon voilà est-ce que je
peux avoir des éléments et pardonnez moi
de vous faire peut-être répéter je vous
laisse répondre à toutes celles ci merci
merci pour ces questions alors sur sur
le fait que le découragement ou le
décrochage en tout cas des internes en
médecine
là dessus on a malheureusement pas de
données on a connaissance de cas
individuels de personnes qui ont arrêté
leurs études
particulièrement après après après ce
qui s'est passé pendant la crise qu vide
je pense que inde et des premiers
facteurs malheureusement ça a été un
facteur financier parce que comme l'a
dit julien il ya certains internes qui
n'ont pas été payés pendant cet épisode
de crise déjà par le passé il faut
savoir que la question financière est
quand même et quand même un frein et
entraîne un décrochage d'un certain
nombre d'internats interne en moyenne
s'est payé 1800 euros nets et bas à
paris il ya un certain nombre d'entre
eux qui quand on a 25 ans une famille
arrive pas sûr avec avec un tel salaire
et préfère prendre un boulot
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants
ou carrément de changer de voie moi ça a
été encore plus plus compliqué et
surtout je pense qu'il ya un sentiment
qui a été très important ça a été suite
se dire que les internes était dangereux
pour leurs familles vous allez
travailler
moi j'ai eu j'ai eu des cas on m'a
rapporté des gens qui ne rentraient plus
chez eux
allez à l'hôtel par peur de contaminer
de contaminer leurs familles et ça ça
fait partie des choses qui bien entendu
vous des motifs de cette de cette
formation
alors malheureusement on a très peu de
données sur sur le décrochage le l'ordre
national des médecins avaient avait
sorti la statistique de 20% des
étudiants qui décrocherait entre le
début de leurs études et la fin mais
malheureusement actuellement il n'ya il
n'ya pas de suivi des étudiants en
médecine entre la première et la
dernière année il n'y a pas de
statistiques on est incapable de nous
dire combien il ya de suicides combien
il ya d'arrêt maladie
ceci n'est pas étudiée donc certes il ya
une pénurie de médecins mais si on ne
connaît pas les statistiques déjà du
décrochage et des causes du décrochage
on ne pourra pas résoudre cette question
alors après il ya deux façons de faire
ce soit enfin c'est un verre qui se
remplit et malheureusement qui fuit donc
on a deux solutions soit son boucher la
fuite sont augmentés le remplissage pour
ce qui est des feedbacks temps qu'on a
passé statistiques malheureusement ne
pourra rien faire pour ce qui est
d'augmenter le remplissage comme vous
l'avait bien dit les capacités de
formation
elles sont actuellement quand même
largement saturé c'est un sentiment
qu'on ressent dans quasiment toutes les
subdivisions et dans quasiment toutes
les spécialités notamment les
spécialités d'anesthésie-réanimation on
voit pas vraiment comment est-ce qu'on
serait en capacité de former de former
plus d'un terne
alors il ya bien des il ya bien des
pistes qui sont évoqués mais comme vous
l'avez évoqué nécessairement ça demande
plus de moi
universitaire que ce qu'on a
actuellement vous avez vous aviez posé
une dernière question excusez moi je
crois que j'ai vu sur les sur les heures
de travail je suis je suis désolé nous
n'avons pas nous n'avons pas compté les
heures de travail pendant cette période
qu vite je pense que ça a été ça a été
bien supérieur d'un autre côté il ya
aussi certains internes dans certaines
spécialités qui se sont retrouvés
complètement à l'arrêt et sans la
capacité d'aider d'autres personnes donc
je ne peux pas donner je peux pas donner
de chiffres précis ce qu'on sait c'est
que voilà en 2019 on a fait une rare
fait notre étude sur le temps de travail
on n'a retrouvé que 56 étaient 56 heures
hebdomadaires en moyenne que 10 % des
internes font plus de 79 heures par
semaine particulièrement des internes de
chirurgie que le repos de sécurité et de
moins en moins respectée et un tiers des
internes qui dit ne pas prendre son
repos de sécurité donc après une garde
de 24 heures systématiquement sur cette
donnée là ça s'aggrave par rapport à
en 2012 on avait déjà fait une enquête
qui a retrouvé un temps de travail
exorbitants qui avait entraîné par la
commission européenne une auto saisie
qui avait demandé à modifier le décret
sur le temps de travail
le décret avait été modifié sauf que le
problème c'est qu'actuellement le décret
qui est qui qui est en cours pour nous
il est très problématique parce que
notre temps de travail il n'est pas
défini comme d'autres en heure ou ou en
quoi que ce soit il est défini en demi
journée et quand je vais travailler la
nuit pendant 14 heures d'affilée ça va
me décompter deux demi journées
donc vous comprenez que partant de là
notre travail il peut pas être il peut
pas être correct la demi-journée elle
est pas définie elle n'est pas borné
et en pratique personne n'arrive à faire
respecter ce texte et on a beau parler
derrière le ministre maintient qu'il va
y avoir des sanctions sur les hôpitaux
qui ne respectent pas le texte
on dit que ce texte il c'est pas
possible de c'est pas possible de le
mettre en application un système qui va
juste compter des demi journées et qui
pour une nuit vous compte deux demi
journées ça ne permettra jamais
d'atteindre des conditions de travail
satisfaisantes
on demande ce qu'on demande en fait
c'est beaucoup plus de contrôle beaucoup
plus de deux forces des ressources
humaines est hélas a rejoint un peu
votre question madame vermeille et c'est
les ressources humaines hospitalière
elle aussi son déficit de personnel et
n'arrivent pas à assurer leurs fonctions
il ya une fonction essentielle des
ressources humaines qui est celle de la
prévention des risques psychosociaux et
notamment du décompte horaire du temps
de travail et ça c'est absolument pas
fait nulle part et pour les internes
encore moins que pour le reste des des
praticiens de l'hôpital et c'est ce qui
fait aussi que derrière ces services de
ressources humaines quand il se retrouve
face à une crise sanitaire ne sont pas
en capacité de les gérer merci monsieur
roger karoutchi
pardon monsieur le président mais est-ce
que les sentiments c'était ma question
c'est est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que cette deuxième vague
pour cette deuxième vague il y a eu une
prise en compte de vos aux
avertissements de vaud de vos analyses
et que rien devant être mieux
très très très honnêtement non j'étais
absolument aucun espoir là dessus
d'autant plus d'autant plus à la lecture
des résultats du secteur de la santé
veut dire le secteur de la santé on a
obtenu et on a dû se battre pour ça
d'arriver à être payés au smic horaire
voilà ce qu'on a obtenu ce sur le temps
de travail
il ya eu aucune écoute non non j'ai
complètement pessimiste et là où par
contre nous on a un retour d'expérience
c'est que comme lady julien énormément
en interne sont épuisés et ils ont
compris que eux-mêmes en fait s'il
allait se porter volontaire s'il allait
aider dans les services il se mettait en
danger ils le feront plus monsieur
karoutchi
bon elle a sincèrement j'espère qu'on
n'aura pas le coc vide parce que s'il
faut aller à l'hôpital ferez pas rassuré
comme disent qu'il faut y aller parce
qu'en fait si je comprends bien vous
dites que en gros la moitié des internes
ont un retard de formation ou ne sont
pas formés à la prise en charge de
patients qu'ovide vous parler évidemment
des problèmes psychologiques de d'un
grand nombre d'un terne
vous imaginez ce que ça veut dire
d'entendre ça pour les éventuels
patients parce qu'ils se disent eh ben
c'est pas c'est pas gagné 1 c'est pas
gagner j'espère que je vais rester en
bonne santé
moi je dois dire j'ai un peu de mal un
peu de mal parce que on a fait venir ici
sous serment sous serment des ministres
des directeurs généraux de la santé des
responsables de rs des tous les oiseaux
ils nous ont tous dit alors vous
n'imaginez pas ce qu'on a appris depuis
mars
vous n'imaginez pas combien on a
actualisé les relations fait en sorte
qu'ils aient plus de fluidité fait en
sorte que l'hôpital répondent mieux qu
en sorte que les blocages administratifs
réglementaires soient levés
parce que on sait bien que l'épidémie et
l'année n'est pas terminée
et puis quand on vous entend on a plutôt
tendance à se dire en fait
les blocages sont pas levées les
relations inter hôpitaux sont pas
meilleurs qui a sept ou huit mois la
formation des personnels à l'hôpital
n'est pas meilleure qu'à sept huit mois
sur la prise en charge qu'ovide j'ai un
peu tenté de dire bon jeu moi je
comprends très bien que le c ur n'est
pas donné satisfaction sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais si on voulait si
vous voulez on a le droit d'espérer
quelques éléments un peu comment dire
optimistes
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'au
moins sur certains sujets la prise en
charge l'organisation le la capacité
hospitalière a évolué en huit ou neuf
mois ou est ce que vous nous dites
aujourd'hui nous praticiens direct dans
les hôpitaux
nous vous disons tranquillement que mi
octobre 2020 on n'est pas mieux équipés
pas mieux formés pas plus s'équiper pas
plus fort mais que nous l'étions au mois
de mars
en clair courage
oui attention votre réponse ne voyez pas
notre collègue je suis au suicide ce
serait dommage on regretterait alesi
répond b 6e
je crois que je crois que vous je vais
répondre à cette recherche d'optimisme
mais mais mais d'abord je crois que vous
soulevez un point qui est important
c'est si les questions des
interlocuteurs ce qu'on s'est rendu
compte pendant cette crise c'est qu'en
fait on avait l'expérience de h1n1 et
pendant 1 h aréna
les syndicats professionnels avaient été
beaucoup consulté notamment les
syndicats d'internet étant donné que ces
internes qui avait fait beaucoup de
vaccination ce qu'on s'est rendu compte
dans cette crise c'est que déjà on
n'était plus un interlocuteur des
gestions de crise sanitaire et qu'en
plus les interlocuteurs qui désormais
été choisis étaient les fédérations
hospitalières fédéral fhf et fhp
moi j'ai rien contre les comptes les
fédérations tout au contraire
mais le dialogue avec les avec les
professionnels et leurs représentants
c'est quelque chose d'inestimable si on
veut connaître les réalités du terrain
on ne peut pas faire sans or force est
de constater que cette modification des
interlocuteurs aujourd'hui elle continue
quand on voit que le comité de suivi du
ségur ne sont invités aux réunions de
suivi que les représentants signataires
des accords ça veut dire qu'il ya la
moitié des représentants du personnel
qui sont évincés des discussions et ça
c'est gravissime parce que c'est pas
parce que la cgt ou jeune médecin ou
actions praticiens hospitaliers n'ont
pas signé les accords que ils ont pas
quand même une valeur à apporter dont
justement cette transformation du
système de santé
et ça je trouve ça très grave après si
on doit chercher de l'optimisme
moi je vois des choses très positives
mais mais ces choses positives elles
sont elles sont surtout dans dans le
retournement de notre société c'est à
dire qu'enfin la santé est devenue un
sujet prioritaire à la fois dans les
médias et aussi dans les politiques
publiques
quand on est invité ici c'est un signe
positif parce qu'on peut parler aussi
nos conditions de travail
chose qui à une époque aurait été aurait
été plus difficile en tout cas ce
n'était pas un sujet qui était sous le
feu des projecteurs et nous ça nous ça
nous a aidé pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail
et puis que la société civile se
prennent en main ces questions
maintenant il faut arriver à transformer
l'essai quand quand on voit que il ya eu
un projet de loi de la sécurité sociale
avec un monde dames qui nous envoient
encore vers des restrictions budgétaires
eh ben ça veut dire qu'on va encore
fermé des lits voilà on en a fermé mais
on va fermer près de 2000 en 2019
tendent en 2019 lui et voilà on prévoit
en 2021 l'enfermer encore on prévoit de
faire encore des économies
je veux dire quand on regarde les
conditions de travail il n'ya pas que
les questions liées à la crise sanitaire
s'est vu les conditions de travail
étaient très mauvaises
rien que sur l'hôtellerie par exemple
sur la qualité des chambres de garde
je veux dire on nous demande de dormir
dans des endroits qui sont insalubres
avec des fenêtres qui ne ferment pas
avec pas de draps on paye des repas on
nous sert un bol de riz du morceau de
pain et enrc nature il faut comprendre
que ça les personnels hospitaliers y
partent on a beau lever tous les
blocages et ses tanks ont fait un peu
attention à nos personnels et qu'on fait
pas attention à l'égard des notamment
sur sur les sur les manières de les
accueillir les gens vont partir
voilà là il ya un tiers des postes de
praticiens hospitaliers qui sont vacants
donc beaucoup d'infirmiers il ya
beaucoup de lit qui sont fermées par
manque de personnel et là effectivement
on a besoin d'un choc d'autres activités
on n'arrête pas de l'appeler mais on a
besoin de le voir
et puis et puis on a besoin de faire
revenir des personnels sinon non ça va
pas s'améliorer donc l'optimisme c'est
que vraiment et la société prennent en
charge ces mesures et fasse en sorte
qu'ils aient à nouveau les moyens
nécessaires pour faire fonctionner
correctement le système de santé pour
pour compléter un peu c'est moi j'ai
l'impression également que ce qui est
positif dans cette crise fait que les
professionnels de santé sont plaints de
résilience et c'est que quelque part
dans ce chaos qui a été la crise
sanitaire
il ya aussi un sens c'est qu'en fait la
santé publique et la santé de la
population c'est aussi le coeur de notre
métier c'est pour ça qu'on est là
par contre on nous donne pas les moyens
de le faire et ça part et ça comme tu le
disais il ya vraiment ce sentiment
mélangé de colère et de peur quand on va
à l'hôpital tous lés jours maintenant
j'ai pas l'impression que par contre
vraiment dans le même sens que la
gestion rh à l'hôpital n'ait changé
vraiment l'hôpital pour moi il redevenu
le même qu'avant la crise qu'ovide la
gestion rh ont exactement les mêmes on a
exactement le même niveau de lits fermés
par manque de personnel dans les
hôpitaux
ce dont je continue de m'étonner
actuellement ce qui m'étonnait déjà
pendant la première vague c'est que il
ya quelqu'un qui a un pouvoir de
réquisition des professionnels de santé
et il n'a toujours pas été utilisé les
hôpitaux manquent de professionnels les
préfets ont la possibilité de
réquisitionner les professionnels de
santé ça n'a pas été fait et ça n'est
pas encore fait pourtant il ya des
grilles de rémunérations qui sont
prévues pour les personnes de santé
réquisitionnés
ça n'est toujours pas fait donc moi
qu'est ce que je dis à mes interne qui
veulent pas retourner à l'hôpital et d
une deuxième fois pour ne pas être payés
pendant trois mois et qu'à côté de ça il
ya un décret spécifique qui écrit noir
sur blanc ce qui doivent être payés
pendant une réquisition et qui les
payent beaucoup mieux que le smic
horaire pendant une garde de 12 ou 24
heures
qu'est ce que je leur dis merci bien
bréville
merci monsieur le président merci pour
votre présentation qui s'était bien
comme ça ça l'était j'avoue je suis très
ému en fait parce que je salue en je
salue en vous l'engagement de la
jeunesse et je voudrais vous faire
préciser deux trois petites choses que
je crois avoir compris donc bon très
généralement on voit bien qu'il y a eu
un manque d'organisation totale dans la
gestion de cette crise est-ce que j'ai
bien compris que vous avez pris les
devants pour vous organiser et que
personne en fait ne vous avez sollicité
pour cela
est ce que c'est bien ça ensuite est-ce
que vous avez eu l'impression que vous
aviez devancé ou que ça allait venir
éventuellement cette organisation ou pas
ensuite vous avez bien mentionné que
c'est vous qui savez le mieux qu'elle
interne est capable de faire ceci ou
cela et que donc dans une dans un avenir
si on devait organiser davantage la la
gestion d'une crise vous pourriez être à
même de d'être
à la manoeuvre en fait pour faire ce que
vous avez fait d'ailleurs de vous même
et moi je voulais aussi vous demander
sur la formation dont vous dites que une
grande faim 46% ont eu le sentiment de
ne pas avoir été formés est ce qu'il
faudrait l'inscrire dorénavant dans les
formations et puis dernière chose vous
avez dit que vous n'aviez pas pu suivre
tout votre cursus habituel et mais
malgré tout vous avez vous avez agi
pendant la crise et est-ce que ça ça ne
pourrait pas faire l'objet d'une espèce
de valorisation dans l'obtention de vos
diplômes parce que vous avez quand même
dû et puis on voit avec quelle énergie
vous avez fait ça donc valoriser cette
chose-là et et permettre que ça que ça
rentre en compte et que ça puisse faire
en sorte que vous puissiez obtenir vos
diplômes plus facilement
voilà je vous remercie merci merci pour
ces questions et fait effectivement
effectivement c c mobilisent à notre
propre initiative pour vous dire on a
fait une assemblée générale qui est qui
a regroupé près de 80 personnes de
matières de manière dématérialisée
nomination dans toute la france et
devant l'absence de consignes on a
décidé de s'organiser nous-mêmes et
effectivement on pense que c'est que
c'est ce qui fonctionne le mieux
ce conte ce qu'on déplore c'est que
derrière l'administration a eu un
certain un délai pour pour se mettre en
place et que souvent ça a été un frein
et que ce qui nous a au final donner le
plus de travail ça va pas et étant
d'identifier les services où il y avait
besoin de renfort est de trouver des
volontaires et de déplacer des personnes
parce qu'en pratique énormément en
interne se sont portés volontaires ce
qui a été le plus difficile ça a été de
les faire payer
ça constitue en quelque sorte c'est
l'aspect optimiste de la chose c'est que
vous avez été très réactifs et que vous
avez
organiser quelque chose qui n'était pas
prévue par les autorités
ah oui là la mobilisation d internat
elle a été incroyable c'est vraiment on
a lancé des questionnaires et on avait
près de 90% des internes qui avaient
répondu et qu'ils sont mais qui qui sont
recensés qui ont mis leurs compétences
et qui étaient volontaires pour pour se
mobiliser
julien disait attendre les réquisitions
voulait pas attendre les réquisitions
parce qu'on voulait pas attendre que ce
soit un préfet une administration qui
connaît pas les réalités de terrain qui
nous met au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
mais c'est sur que derrière quand on se
retrouve avec des antennes qui sont pas
payer ses fins
ça pue ça passe ça paraît encore en ré
semblables excusez-moi j'ai oublié les
autres mais sur la valorisation de
l'expérience
en fait nos diplômes nos diplômes on
finira par les avoir en fait pour être
pour être interne faut faire faut faire
sur tous ces stages pratiques en francs
on fera en sorte de on fera en sorte de
rattraper nos stages ils seront quand
même validé le problème c'est la qualité
de ses dribbles de ses diplômés de la
formation qu'on a obtenu dire quand on
se passe de trois mois de formation on
se passe de trois mois de formation si
on veut le récupérer il faut refaire
trois mois de formation derrière donc
c'est un temps perdu qu'on récupérera
pas et on j'ai beau réfléchir et tournai
question dans tous les sens à moins de
faire trois mois de formation plus fins
de l'internât et pai apparent de façon
de valoriser ça après ce sera valorisé
parce que ben il y en a beaucoup qui ont
appris dans à faire affaire de
l'organisationnel et de l'est de la
santé publique et ça c'est clairement
c'est nécessaire et il ya un grand
déficit en france sur la formation de
tous les médecins à la santé publique
parce que d'accord on a une spécialité
de santé publique avec des médecins qui
ne font que de la santé publique
néanmoins nous ce qu'on dit c'est que
tous les médecins devraient car des
compétences en santé publique et pas
qu'eux aussi en gestion de projet en
communication en gestion de personnel et
pour ça ce qu'on aurait besoin c'est que
les facultés de médecine elle s'ouvre
sur l'université
ce qui est actuellement pas le cas parce
que actuellement les facultés de
médecine sont enclavés ce ne sont que
des médecins qui y forment d'autres
médecins pour ce qui est de 6 on a
devancé en fait la réponse des
administrations
face à cette crise sanitaire en ce qui
concerne l'île de france on a vraiment
travaillé main dans la main avec la
grèce ile de france alors oui peut-être
que parce que on était au courant de la
situation par nos collègues en géo en
région grand est
on est arrivé avec une solution clé en
main à l'aéro près de las heras
ile-de-france en leur disant bon voilà
nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est ça il va
falloir que tout le monde se mette
d'accord pour qu'on puisse proposer des
réaffectations d'internât en
ile-de-france avec la corde
ces directeurs de formation et des
doyens et ils nous ont dit banco en fait
parce que effectivement je pense que il
n'allait pas avoir les données et les
réponses que que nous que nous avions
parce que on est on croulait déjà sous
les sollicitations d'un terne qui parce
qu'ils étaient passés dans un service
particulier qui il savait avait besoin
dead ont pu les rejoindre mais il y
avait des internes tous les jours toutes
les deux minutes on avait un nouveau
message qui nous est où est ce que je
veux ou est-ce que je vais et on avait
besoin de répondre à ces internats qui
en fait que la rs ou que les facultés de
médecine en fait ont beaucoup de mal à
approcher autrement et si on était
capable de refaire la même chose là
actuellement je suis pas sûr parce que
c'était vraiment une conjonction très
spécial c'est que on avait beaucoup
d'internautes était en situation de
grossesse qui ont pu nous aider dans la
gestion vraiment administrative delà des
flux mais on avait également beaucoup
d'internautes qui étaient en recherche
et en fait
du coup qui étaient dans des
laboratoires qui ont fermé sauf que là
en fait c'est la période de l'année
actuellement où les internes ne sont pas
en laboratoire ils sont en enseignements
donc je sais pas avec l interne je
pourrai refaire ça bien on va vous
remercier messieurs il ya plus de
questions
madame de roche peut-être vous n'avez
pas tellement parler de la situation
actuelle le regard sur sur les mesures
prises actuellement
parce que ce qu'on ressent c'est
maintenant que l'épidémie est et sur
tout le territoire avec des degrés -
bien sûr mais surtout le territoire
alors qu'avant on est passé d'une phase
dans le grand test pour la phase ile de
france et des régions ailleurs plutôt
épargné comment ça se passe maintenant
est ce que est ce que dans les services
vos collègues vous disent nous on est en
tension en effet il faut pas que ça
augmente trop parce qu'on n'a pas de
réserve pour faire venir quelqu'un
comment ça marche parce que oui ce qui
est difficile à faire comprendre c'est
des mesures très restrictive qui sont
présents je ne juge pas mais alors que
si on regarde objectivement ses 1500
personnes en réanimation sur tout le
territoire et donc comment vous
expliquer sa selle la situation actuelle
comment vous la voyez vous ce qui ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est quand on parle de quand on parle
de patients qu'aux vide en réanimation
c'est en plus des autres patients or les
services de réanimation en temps normal
ils sont déjà ils sont déjà remplies
donc là c'est des patients qui arrivent
en plus la situation
sympa c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté sur
le contexte c'est que la situation dans
lequel est arrivée la crise qu vide pour
les hôpitaux elle était déjà était déjà
extrêmement tendue en terme de manque de
moyens de personnel et de saturation des
10 donc là on est dans une situation où
très clairement les capacités elles sont
largement dépassées et en plus on a
quand même tous peur parce que on sait
qu'il ya la grippe saisonnière qui va
arriver
donc non là dessus là dessus on trouve
que toutes les mesures sanitaires qui
peuvent être pris pour limiter la
propagation du virus elles sont bonnes
est ce qu'il faut bien voir aussi c'est
que en plus de en plus des vagues
d'épidémie là ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il ya la fatigue des personnels et la
fatigue
enfin la fatigue des personnels ses
mains et c'est maintenant qu avec l
arrivée ils n'ont pas pu le prendre de
congés cet été ils ont dû se mobiliser
bah inéluctablement on aura plus
on aura plus de réserve comme on a pu
avoir lors de la première vague
surtout que là aussi c'est un monde
ensuite concerne des internes c'est un
moment particulier là on est le 15
octobre dans quinze jours il ya 8000
nouveaux internes qui arrive en est qui
arrive sur la france entière
il y en a huit mille qui partent qu'ils
sont diplômés donc sur le territoire il
va y avoir huit nouveaux médecins
diplômés et va y avoir huit mille
nouveaux médecins qui seront en
formation qui vont apprendre leur
spécialité ce qu'on sait déjà - en tout
cas localement c'est de toute façon le
plan blanc et déjà réactive en
ile-de-france donc les congés des
professionnels sont annulés fortement
conseillé d'annuler ses crochets moi
j'ai plein de situations internes qui en
fait du coup n'ont pas pris de congé
depuis un an parce que n'ont pas pu en
prendre pour de la première crise n'ont
pas pu en prendre cet été parce que
habituellement les internes sont là pour
tenir le service l'été pendant que les
médecins à diplôme et sans vacances et
nous on prend nos vacances en septembre
octobre et la deuxième faille
oui c'est ça aussi c'est que là il ya
déjà le ras-le-bol se faisait pressentir
précédemment parce que comme tu l'a
rappelé justin on a eu un mouvement de
grève avant avant la crise sanitaire qui
appelait à plus de moyens pour l'hôpital
public qui est notre outil de formation
mais là en fait on s'est bien rendu
compte en fait plus que des limites de
la gestion hospitalière de la limite de
la limite de la gestion de la santé en
france
on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait il y
avait un problème systémique que même
s'il y avait une crise sanitaire et que
tout le monde a été plein de bonne
volonté et ben en fait était plein de
choses qui bloquait pas de partout que
ce soit administrative que ce soit
financier là les internes je pense que
il y leurs espoirs et leur volonté de
leur volonté de directement aller au
front
si une deuxième vague là c'est un peu
entachée oui ils iront mais je ne sais
pas comment
oui et non parce que ce qui est sûr
c'est que les intervenants continuent et
vont continuer à se mobiliser au maximum
de leurs capacités
c'est sur leur capacité que j'ai plus de
doute et il va quand même
enfin les premiers jours de novembre
vont quand même être une période
particulière dans les hôpitaux français
suit comme lady julien il ya 8000
nouveaux internes qui arrive qui ont
jamais eu ses fonctions de prescripteurs
et qui encore aujourd'hui c'est
malheureux de le dire mais se retrouve
du jour au lendemain en charge de
patients est quasiment quasiment
seulement les services donc c'est
toujours une période particulier le mois
de novembre
et là en plus avec avec la période cosy
de ça va pas être le moment de se faire
hospitaliser et mercy est d'autant plus
et d'autre est d'autant plus lors de la
crise sanitaire les hospitalisations
qu'ovide on arrivait à les restreindre
c'était il y avait des services qu vides
il y avait des réanimations qu'ovide la
maintenant en fait le coville il touche
toutes les toute la population donc il
va falloir en fait avoir des lits de
gériatrie de covile il va falloir avoir
été un des valeurs à avoir de la
médecine interne déco vide
l'ensemble de l'organisation
hospitalière va devoir se réorganiser
avec ail toute la population qui manque
qui peut maintenant être infectées et
sauf qu'en fait c'est lilas de
typiquement de gériatrie qui est un
service très important pour l'hôpital
parce que c'est un lit c'est des
services d'aval particulièrement des
urgences c'est particulièrement celles
qui sont fermées par manque de personnel
et et moi je suis interne de psychiatrie
donc je prêche aussi pour ma paroisse
mais pour la psychiatrie ça a été
d'autant plus désastreux là les la suite
de la première vague ont été
catastrophiques dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques on as dans les services
de psychiatrie on a eu énormément de
demandes de soins pour plein de
problématiques de santé différentes mais
les hôpitaux psychiatriques en france
ils sont dans une situation autant voire
bien plus compliquée que les hôpitaux
généraux et là par exemple moi pour le
terrain en ile de france il ya des
services et des hôpitaux qui n'ont plus
du tout un lit depuis plusieurs mois dès
qu'on fait sortir quelqu'un on a déjà
dix personnes qui attendent
je me permets d'insister sur sur ce qui
est dit julien parce que c'est vrai que
dans notamment dans les médias il ya un
biais qu'on entend c'est que on ne parle
que de réanimation et de lits de
réanimation
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les patients avant d'être en réanimation
et sont hospitalisées dans des services
de médecine que dans ses services de
médecine il ya particulièrement pas de
moyens et quand la nuit il ya une
infirmière qui va gérer 28 patients
vous avez une urgence les 27 autres sont
des auto entrepreneurs ça il faut il
faut arriver à bien le comprendre et ne
pas se focaliser uniquement sur la
question de la réanimation les besoins
ils sont particuliers quand même en
médecine en service de médecine
là dessus il faut il va falloir
augmenter les moyens et surtout les
moyens des paramédicaux aussi un message
que je peux faire passer c'est que ok il
ya un manque de médecins il manque un
tiers des postes de péage les internes
ils sont là ils resteront là les
effectifs sont stables
là où il ya vraiment des manques et une
fuite de personnel c'est
particulièrement chez les infirmiers et
aides soignants qui vivent des
conditions de travail qui sont qu'ils
sont
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont terribles
merci messieurs quelques petites
observations en ce qui me concerne pour
essayer de rassurer nos collègues j'ai
là le rapport d'étape de la mission
indépendante qui avait été nommé par le
président de la république
pour ce qui est des excès de mortalité
en france
l'excellent mentalités en france est de
28 mille trois cent six c'est vrai qu'il
est en allemagne de 7552 seulement mais
par ailleurs il est de 47 1484 en italie
46 1742 en espagne 5197 en suède
proportionnellement à la population
c'est beaucoup plus qu'en france 57 1844
au royaume uni et 190 milles aux états
unis il ya par là que la situation de la
france n'est certainement pas bonne mais
elle n'est pas catastrophique
le deuxième point qui me semble
important dans ce que vous aviez je vous
rejoins complètement sur les hôpitaux
psychiatriques les hôpitaux psychiatrie
c est un problème de financement
ils sont actuellement financés sous
forme de dotation annuelle est la
meilleure solution serait certainement
de trouver un autre type de financement
peut-être pas l'activité à un t2
incomplète parce que ça posera un
problème majeur mais un mélange des deux
serait pas inutile mais enfin je
voudrais revenir sur ce que vous avez
dit vous monsieur le président si on le
financement de la sécurité sociale
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
il faut donner à l'ensemble des
personnels soignants de ce pays
les moyens de travailler mais pour cela
il faut et que le gouvernement et que le
parlement
l'ensemble du parlement accepte le
principe d'un ondam au moins quatre
c'est à dire donc donné chaque année aux
soignants à la santé française 8
milliards de plus mais pas huit
milliards de plus en 2021
et puis ensuite on court les 8 milliards
de puces chaque année il faudra trouver
l'argent sur ce merci à vous
et bonne journée mais alors laurence ta
solution et je les accepte à condition
qu'ils acceptent la mienne aussi ta
solution j accepte à condition qu'ils
acceptent la mienne également on en
parle
y'a pas de soucis mais merci à tous
merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette audition des syndicats
d'un terne des hôpitaux des syndicats
qui étaient donc entendue par la
commission d' enquête consacrée à la
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus on
passe à une autre audition à présent
florence parly a été entendu par la
commission des affaires étrangères
une audition initialement consacré au
budget 2021 et vous allez le voir elle a
très vite dévié sur le mali le mali et
la libération de sophie petrona on
regarde on en reparle juste après
d'aborder le budget je veux vous
interrogez vous aurez l'occasion de nous
dire ce que vous en pensez
à la demande de nombreux nombre de nos
collègues sur les conditions de la
libération de l'otage française au mali
si bien évidemment la libération d'une
otage est toujours une bonne nouvelle
nous avons été quelque peu interpellé
ici à la commission de la défense par
les conditions dans lesquelles cet otage
s'est retrouvé libre
nous souhaitons le rappeler ici la
france déploie à la demande du
gouvernement malien
cinq mille cinq cents hommes au mali
petit peu moins et ce pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
nous avons
perdu 50 soldats
1 hélas depuis le début de ses
opérations et près de 500 militaires ont
été lourdement blessé et donc nous avons
une pensée pour eux puisque dans les
libérations qui sont intervenus même
s'il apparaît que une partie conséquente
d'entre les les gens qui ont été libérés
tous ne sont pas des djihadistes mais on
a pu identifier un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui eux ont du sang sur les
mains et notamment ont participé à des
attentats dans lequel des français et
des soldats maliens aussi en grand
nombre ont pu laisser la vie et donc on
peut légitimement en tous les cas je
pense que c'est notre rôle
on peut s'interroger sur les conditions
dans lesquelles cette libération s'est
engagée comment est ce que vous avez été
consultés comment le gouvernement le
président de la république lui-même
comment avez vous pu une part du reste
peut-être être associé à la libération
de ces de ces prisonniers est ce qu'il
ya une consultation de des crimes ou des
délits qui leur étaient reprochés
et dans ces conditions est-ce que l'on
peut encore considérer que la junte
actuellement au pouvoir
au mali est un partenaire de confiance
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme que
nos soldats mène avec tellement de
courage tellement d'abnégation et bien
évidemment si la france n'était pas au
courant c'est tout aussi inquiétant que
si elle l'était puisque bien évidemment
ça ça pose des problèmes encore une fois
de ce partenariat de confiance que nous
souhaitons avec les dirigeants maliens
dont je rappelle que c'est à la suite
d'une demande du gouvernement précédent
que nous sommes présents là bas et nous
avons évidemment une pensée pour ce que
pensent les familles familles de nos
soldats tués nous familles de soldats
blessés donc je voulais vous en faire
part et vous dire que notre inquiétude
est vive sur la situation de barkan dans
ces conditions et je pense que mes
collègues seront attentifs à vos
réponses
alors j'en viens maintenant plus
directement à l'objet de cette audition
sur les questions budgétaires
nos collègues vont pouvoir puisque les
rapporteurs ne sont pas désignés le
seront la semaine prochaine le bureau
vient de se réunir et nous avons tracé
les perspectives du travail que nous
allons accomplir mais donc d'y filmer
différents collègues auront l'occasion
de vous interroger sur les questions
budgétaires
j'aurais simplement pour ouvrir le débat
est planté en quelque sorte le décor de
cette audition vous rappeler trois
préoccupations fortes qui ont toujours
été celles de la commission
bien sûr et en tout premier lieu de 2021
sera l'année de l'actualisation de la
loi de programmation militaire
c'est un dernier c'est un rendez vous
particulièrement important d'autant que
on s'en souvient les dernières marches
de la lpm sont particulièrement hot et
elles seront sans doute encore plus
difficile à gravir que nous l'imaginions
à l'époque au moment du vote puisque le
co vide est venu porter une ombre
budgétaire avec des prises en charge de
beaucoup de dérèglements que connaît
notre économie notre société et donc il
n'est pas dans notre esprit n'est pas
question que ce soit la loi de
programmation militaire qui fasse les
frais de ces engagements de dépenses
et une loi bien évidemment nous
souhaitons leur préciser une loi ne peut
être actualisée que par une loi
c'est l'esprit et la pratique des
institutions
donc ce que l'on espère c'est que bien
évidemment le gouvernement puisse
revenir devant le parlement lorsque des
mesures d'actualisation de la lpm seront
arrêtés et donc vous nous direz un petit
peu quel est le point de vue
quel est votre point de vue sur ce sujet
est-ce qu'on a d'ores et déjà un
calendrier pour pouvoir travailler
encore une fois sur cette actualisation
de la lpm le deuxième sujet d'importance
eh bien c'est la question que nous avons
eu l'occasion d'évoquer les uns et les
autres
lorsque le plan de relance du
gouvernement a fait l'objet d'une
communication au public
on a constaté que ce plan de relance ne
comportait pas de véritable volet de
soutien à l'industrie de défense et donc
alors même qu'on sait que l'emploi
l'effet sur l'emploi et sur la balance
extérieure est à la fois vérifié tout à
fait réelle
on a un petit peu le sentiment mais vos
éclaircissements vont peut nous
permettre de mieux comprendre le
raisonnement gouvernement on a un peu
l'impression que c'est un rendez vous
manqué et que le plan de relance aurait
pu être peut-être un peu plus orienté
vers les dépenses relatives à la défense
et aux industries de défense qui reste
pour une immense pas des dépenses qui se
font sur le territoire national donc
c'est évidemment un élément important
pour la relance de l'activité
les investissements qui avait été prévu
par la loi de programmation militaire
l'avait été avant la pandémie est donc
maintenant il est ce que le fait de les
recycler aujourd'hui comme une partie du
plan de relance va pouvoir convaincre
les industriels va pouvoir convaincre
les sénateurs
on a des échos qui peuvent être parfois
contradictoires mais on aimerait avoir
votre sentiment sur l'impact du plan de
relance et comment les choses peuvent
s'organiser
enfin dernier dernier point et puis
après les discussions va nous vont nous
permettre d'entrer plus dans le vif du
sujet nous attendons toujours les
arbitrages sur le porte avions de
nouvelle génération ainsi que sur
l'avenir du sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué la perle au moins peut-on
savoir quand ces arbitrages
interviendront de la même manière des
parties de réponses qui ont été accordés
mais je préférais vous entendre sur la
commande des rafale supplémentaires à la
suite du contrat grecque
il ya eu des voix qui se sont élevées
dans la presse mais aussi dans les
milieux informés sur les lesquels la
sphère des des rafales qui vont être
vendues à la grèce était certes un
élément très important c'est une brique
en termes d' europe de la défense du
construction de l europe de la défense
mais notre souci à nous c'est de de ne
pas affaiblir nos forces françaises
puisque globalement il s'agit quand même
de l'équivalent d'un escadron et donc
vous nous direz un peu comment vous
voyez les choses et si vous pensez que
l'industriel peut raisonnablement
augmenter ses cadences de production
pour limiter l'impact sur l'armée de
l'air voilà madame la ministre je vais
vous laisser la parole je rappelle que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo que nous sommes aussi en
correspondance avec nos collègues qui
nous suivent par cette vidéo
transmission et leur rappeler que en
s'inscrivant ils auront la possibilité
de prendre la parole
eux aussi madame la ministre encore
merci vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
tout d'abord je voudrais souhaiter la
bienvenue à celles et ceux qui
rejoignent la commission des affaires
étrangères et des forces armées et
redire tout le plaisir que j'ai à
retrouver ce qui est celle qui siégeait
déjà et puis naturellement je voudrais
monsieur le président vous réitérer mes
félicitations pour la confiance que vos
collègues vous ont renouvelé ainsi que
aux membres du bureau de cette
commission
ce soir c'est donc la quatrième année
que j'ai l'honneur de présenter le
budget de la mission défense celui de
l'année 2021 et ce soir c'est la
quatrième année que je présente un
budget en hausse devant votre commission
lorsque je suis arrivé à la tête de ce
ministère en 2017
il s'élevait à 32 milliards 200 millions
d'euros de crédits budgétaires et chaque
année depuis sans exception aucune ce
budget a été constamment augmenté
d'abord de 1 milliard 800 millions
d'euros en 2018
puis à compter de cette date de 1
milliard 700 millions d'euros chacune
des années suivantes
donc avec 39 milliards 200 millions
d'euros en 2021 c'est 7 milliards de
plus dont nos armées disposent pour
s'équiper notamment de matériel moderne
alors cette nouvelle hausse des crédits
et us y est une fierté
et ce n'est pas une surprise car elle
fait partie intégrante du plan de
bataille que ensemble nous avons
construit et que vous avez voté à une
très large majorité il y a deux ans et
ce plan de bataille s'appelle la loi de
programmation militaire
le budget 2021 désarmé respecte donc à
la lettre les engagements et la
trajectoire financière de la loi de
programmation militaire et ceux ci dont
pour la troisième année consécutive de
sa mise en oeuvre
c'est donc en effet pour nous tous je
crois un très grand motif de
satisfaction d'autant plus que certains
d'entre vous ont en mémoire les
nombreuses lois de finances initiale qui
venait contredire
dès la deuxième année de mise en oeuvre
de la lpm
la lpm elle même si je devais donc
résumé le budget 2021 de la mission
défense je dirais que c'est une
démonstration de constance de confiance
et de relance
ce budget c'est celui de la poursuite de
la mission donnée aux armes et les
moyens de protéger la france et les
français
aujourd'hui comme demain et c'est celui
du soutien à notre b itd ce budget 2021
c'est tout d'abord la mise en oeuvre
concrète des engagements pris par le
président de la république dès 2017 qui
poursuit et consolide la remontée en
puissance de nos armées amorcée il ya
maintenant quatre ans avec un mot
d'ordre simple réparer et préparer
réparer d'abord des armées qui était
vieillissante en remplaçant un matériel
souvent très anciens en répondant mieux
aux besoins des militaires qui ont
évolué ces dernières années et en
muscles en des capacités affaiblies par
un budget qui a été trop longtemps une
variable d'ajustement au sein de l'état
et puis préparer c'est préparer l'avenir
la revue stratégique de 2017 a posé le
constat de nouvelles menaces et d'une
multitude d'incertitudes concernant le
futur des relations et des équilibres
entre les puissances
ce qui nous a menés à élaborer une loi
de programmation militaire avec pour
objectif de redonner à la france un
modèle d'armée complet
ce budget 2021 c'est ensuite dans le
contexte particulier que nous
connaissons de crise sanitaire et
économique une contribution essentielle
à la relance économique de notre pays
ces 39 milliards 200 millions d'euros ce
sont 39 milliards 2 qui bénéficient
directement aux entreprises françaises
et aux territoires des quatre coins de
la france et je voudrais ajouter que si
l'on raisonne sur la première partie de
la loi de programmation militaire celle
qui couvre les années 2000 19 à 2023
ce sont donc 110 milliards d'euros qui
seront injectés dans l'économie pour les
seuls équipements
je devrais dire les équipements et les
infrastructures
c'est donc l'équivalent en cinq ans d'un
plan de relance pour les seules
questions de défense
j'aimerais aussi rappeler que nous
n'avons attendu ni le plan de relance ni
le budget 2021 pour apporter un soutien
concret est significatif à notre
économie et en particulier à notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
j'étais par exemple la semaine dernière
en bretagne où j'ai rencontré des
équipes de sabena technics une
entreprise qui est spécialisé dans le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
aéronautique est un sujet comme vous le
savez qui me tient beaucoup à coeur et
sur ce site de dinars le ministère des
armées a permis de préserver 150 emplois
grâce à la commande anticipée d'un avion
léger de surveillance et de
reconnaissance ainsi que de trois avions
ravitailleurs mrtt phoenix que j'avais
eu l'occasion d'annoncer dans le cadre
du plan de soutien à l'aéronautique
l'entreprise que j'ai rencontrés nous a
fait part aussi de sa satisfaction
d'avoir été accompagnée par la petite
équipe que nous avons appelé la
taskforce behi t d qui est chargé au
sein de la direction générale de
l'armement de faire le point sur les
besoins et éventuellement les
difficultés
et plus globalement sur la situation
générale de chacune des entreprises
stratégiques qui composent notre tissu
industriel
nous sommes également engagés pour la
protection nous industrie mais nous
sommes rig anglais pardon également
engagé pour l'emploi puisque le
ministère des armées sera en 2021 le
premier recruteur de france avec près de
27000 recrutement et la poursuite de
l'effort que nous avons amorcé ensemble
depuis le début de la lpm dans les
domaines du renseignement du cyber et du
numérique
alors je vais passer très rapidement en
revue si vous voulez bien
les la manière dont les 39 milliards 200
millions d'euros de ce budget sont
répartis en fonction des quatre axes de
la loi de programmation militaire
c'est-à-dire le renouvellement des
capacités opérationnelles des armes et
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
de vie des personnels militaires et
civils de la défense
la garantie de l'autonomie stratégique
et puis enfin l'innovation pour répondre
aux défis du futur
alors deux phrases sur les équipements
les livraisons et les commandes se
poursuivront pour moderniser les
matériels et les équipements lourds
cirque il faut retenir c'est que sur le
milliard 7,2 croissance du budget 2021
les deux tiers seront consacrés aux
programmes d'armement majeurs pour nos
armées
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de vie des personnes militaires et
civils la défense autrement dit la lpm
hauteur d'homme je vous propose de
retenir quatre éléments clés dans ce
dans ce domaine pour commencer nous
allons affecter 38 millions d'euros au
lancement de la nouvelle politique de
rémunération des militaires c'est un
projet qui était inscrit dans la loi de
programmation militaire et qui vise à
réformer en profondeur le système
extrêmement complexe de la solde des
militaires pour mieux prendre en compte
à la fois les enjeux sociaux qui sont
propres aux militaires et à leurs états
et simplifié également le calcul de leur
solde il s'agit donc d'une première
étape d'un ensemble beaucoup plus vaste
qui se déploiera jusqu'en 2023
deux éléments deuxième élément clé de ce
budget à hauteur d'homme c'est
l'amélioration des conditions
d'hébergement des militaires auquel nous
consacrerons 237 millions d'euros cette
année dans le cadre du programme
hébergement qui prévoit 1 milliard
d'euros sur la durée de la lpr troisième
élément c'est le renouvellement des
petits équipements de nos militaires ce
plan de renouvellement se poursuit les
livraisons des fusils hk 416 franchiront
le cap des cinquante mille à la fin de
l'année 2021 et les gilets pare-balles
de nouvelle génération ont été
distribués à hauteur de 60 mille ainsi
que les ensembles intempéries pour
combattants débarquer qui équiperont
tous les régiments félins à partir de
cette année enfin quatrième élément il
s'agit je crois d'un élément très
important la lumière de la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons c'est
l'accroissement des crédits consacrés au
service de santé des armées
à court terme des moyens financiers
supplémentaires seront mobilisés pour
faire face à l'épidémie j'ai eu
l'occasion de préciser
récemment ces éléments mais au delà je
souhaite que le service de santé des
armées soient consolidées dans sa
mission première qui est celle du
soutien de nos forces armées
troisième pilier de la lpm ce budget 21
contribuera à la consolidation de notre
autonomie stratégique je pense notamment
au développement de nos capacités
spatiales alors que l'armée de l'air est
devenu l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
de façon très récente et auquel nous
consacrerons 624 millions d'euros en
je pense également un élément essentiel
à notre souveraineté qui est porté par
ce budget 2021
il s'agit de la poursuite du
renouvellement des deux composante
aéroportée et océaniques de la
dissuasion française pour 5 milliards
d'euros en 2021
et enfin pour terminer j'en viens au
dernier axe qui la préparation du futur
2021 sera l'année de la commande du
démonstrateur du système de combat
aérien du futur que nous construisons
avec les allemands et les espagnols et
qui devrait en conséquence prendre son
envol en 2026 pour être opérationnel à
l'horizon 2040 la préparation du futur
passe aussi par l'innovation en 2021
nous consacrerons près de 900 millions
d'euros pour concevoir les technologies
de demain et nous sommes donc en bonne
voie vers le milliard d'euros annuels
qui devraient être atteints comme prévue
en 2022
l'année 2000 21 sera également celle de
la mise en oeuvre du nouveau fonds
d'investissement dé finale qui est dotée
de 200 millions d'euros et qui est
consacré au soutien du développement de
technologies duales par le financement
en fonds propres d'entreprises
innovantes
voilà ce que je pouvais dire en quelques
mots et quelques chiffres
je finirai par rappeler que chaque jour
au ministère des armées nous avons
conscience que les français qu'on sorte
des efforts importants pour nous donner
les moyens de notre mission et nous
voulons être digne de leur confiance
notre devoir à tous et donc de mettre en
oeuvre la loi de programmation militaire
qui poursuit cet objectif de veiller à
son exécution et à sa bonne exécution
dans chaque régiment dans chaque unité
en métropole comme en outre-mer et j'y
veillerai personnellement comme je le
fais chaque jour voilà je ne vous ferai
pas plus longue sur la présentation
initiale et général du budget je pense
qu'il y aura de nombreuses questions et
peut-être monsieur le président avant de
m'interrompre je vais répondre aux
quelques questions que vous m'avez que
vous m'avez posé la première concerne la
libération de notre compatriote sophie
petrona après quatre années très
difficiles
c'est un immense soulagement
naturellement que de l'avoir d'avoir vu
revenir sur le sol français c'était la
dernière otage française retenue dans le
monde et je salue également la
libération de soumaïla cissé ancien chef
de file de l'opposition maliennes qui
avait été enlevé en mars dernier alors
qu'il faisait campagne pour les
élections
donc nous avons eu l'occasion de
remercier mes autorités maliennes qui
sont à l'origine de cette libération et
qui en ont planifié et conduit
l'opération
car en effet cette négociation a été
conduite par le mali la décision de
libérer des djihadistes en particulier
est une décision qui appartient aux
seules autorités maliennes qui ont jugé
que cela était indispensable pour
obtenir la libération de soumaïla cissé
pour notre part notre détermination est
intacte pour continuer la lutte contre
le djihadisme et contre le terrorisme
dans cette région il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté
de ce côté et nos partenaires maliens et
sahéliens le savent alors vous avez
demandé si nous étions informés de la
conduite de cette négociation
ce que nous savions c'est que les
autorités maliennes étaient très
déterminés à obtenir la libération de
soumaïla cissé les négociations pour sa
libération ont été ouvertes il y a
plusieurs mois par les autorités
maliennes de l'époque et les nouvelles
autorités ont marqué leur détermination
à les faire aboutir nous avons donc
appris dimanche 4 octobre au soir qu'un
transfert de prisonniers vers tessalit
tu avais commencé et nous avons constaté
que ces négociations étaient donc
parvenu à leur terme et avait permis la
libération non seulement dessous l'homme
soumaila cissé mais également de notre
compatriote sophie petrona vous m'avez
monsieur le président également
interrogé sur les prochaines échéances
qui vont scander l'année 2000 la fin de
l'année 2020 et probablement plus
particulièrement l'année 2000 21 ans
tout d'abord ce n'est un secret pour
personne que l'année 2000 21 sera
l'année de l'actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire
je n'ai pas d'autres commentaires à
faire si ce n'est que nous y travaillons
en ce qui concerne les arbitrages sur le
porte avions charles de gaulle je pense
que ces sondes et des éléments qui
seront portées à votre connaissance
prochainement quand je dis prochainement
très prochainement et pour ce qui
concerne l'avenir de la perle à nous
attendons encore des éléments
complémentaires aux expertises qui ont
été qui ont été lancés depuis lincendie
qui est intervenue au mois de juin très
probablement il faudra avant de pouvoir
avoir une vision définitive sur la
réparabilité de la perle que celles ci
soient transférés à cherbourg et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé que le la perle seraient
convoyées à cherbourg au dernier
trimestre de cette année
donc je pense qu'à la fin de l'année je
serai en mesure de vous répondre de
façon précise sur ce sujet tout comme
sur le précédent c'est à dire le porte
avions car je pense que ces annonces
devraient être faites prochainement sur
le rafale
j'ai été amené en effet à confirmer le
fait que le la commande que la grèce a
adressé à la france de dix-huit rafale
dont six appareils qui sont neufs et
jusqu'à 12 appareils qui pourrait être
d'occasion et donc prélevé sur la flotte
de l'armée de l'air d'une part ne
remettait pas en cause l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés ensemble qu'en
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace ainsi
que la marine c'est bien ça juste
l'armée de l'air parlons l'armée de
l'air et de l'espace disposerait de 129
appareils à l'horizon 2025
donc dans la mesure où jusqu'à douze
appareils pourraient être prélevés pour
satisfaire le contrat grecque
il va de soi que ces appareils seront
compensées et j'ai donc indiqué que
concomitamment à la signature du contrat
grecque qui aussi les choses se
déroulent comme prévu devrait intervenir
dans les prochaines semaines ou
prochains mois eh bien je commanderai 12
avions neufs pour assurer la
neutralisation de ce prélèvement opéré
au au profit des armées grecques
voilà ce que je pouvais dire alors
maintenant j'en viens
un sujet que vous avez monsieur le
président présentait de façon stimulante
c'est à dire le plan de relance
pardonnez moi de ne pas pouvoir vous
suivre lorsque vous dites que les armées
et les industries de défense plus
exactement en seraient les parents
pauvres du plan de relance
d'abord parce que je pense que aucun
ministère aucun secteur industriel ne
bénéficie depuis 2010 est d'un pareil
effort de remise à niveau et
d'investissement j'ai cité les chiffres
je les rappelle 110 milliards d'euros
sur 19 à 23 ce sont des montants qui
sont tout à fait comparables à ceux qui
sont énoncés par ailleurs pour un grand
nombre de secteurs économiques réunis
d'autre part j'ai été je crois à
l'initiative d'un plan de soutien dans
au profit du secteur le plus touché 2 au
sein de nos industries de défense qui le
secteur aéronautique pour lequel nous
avons mobilisé dès le mois de juin des
crédits afin de passer des commandes de
façon anticipée pour assurer la
continuité d'un certain nombre de
chaînes de production non pas seulement
pour les grands donneurs d'ordres mais
aussi pour toutes les pme et entreprises
sous traitantes qui constituent cette
chaîne de valeur de la d industrie de
défense puis le troisième élément que je
voudrais mettre en avant que j'ai
rapidement mentionné dans mon propos
préliminaires c'est le fait que nous
sommes au chevet de l'ensemble de ces
entreprises nous avons demandé à la dg a
après avoir identifié plus de 1000
entreprises qui jouent vraiment un rôle
tout à fait clé dans notre chaîne
deux fournisseurs et donc dans notre
comment dire autonomie industriels ces
entreprises ont été visitées de façon
individuelle et nous avons pour plus du
tiers d'entre elles d'ores et déjà
mobilisé des mesures que j'appellerais
de remédiation qui sont de divers ordres
qui peuvent être des mesures qui sont
liées aux prêts garantis par l'état
chômage partiel bien sûr lorsque c'était
nécessaire mais aussi des mesures
consistant à revoir les plans d'un
comptage pour faciliter et abonder la
trésorerie voire accélérer de façon très
importante la vitesse avec laquelle les
factures étaient payés
donc nous essayons de mobiliser toute
notre attention pour que ces entreprises
quelle que soit leur taille et en
particulier celles qui sont petites
puissent bénéficier de tout le soutien
dont elles ont besoin car elle joue non
seulement un rôle clé dans les
territoires et pour l'emploi de ces
territoires mais elle joue un rôle clé
dans cette chaîne de souveraineté dont
nous sommes les les dépositaires et dont
nous sommes responsables
donc je crois au contraire que ce qui
est important c'est que malgré la crise
économique que nous vivons nous
puissions poursuivre de façon résolue la
mise en oeuvre de notre loi de
programmation militaire parce que celle
ci est la réponse en de premier ordre
aux besoins des industriels de la
défense et je dirais qu'en ces périodes
d'incertitude
ce qui est fondamental c'est que les
industriels disposent de visibilité et
cette visibilité c'est la loi de
programmation militaire qui l'a leur
apporte
voilà monsieur le président ce que je
voulais répondre en quelques mains merci
madame la ministre pour l'ensemble de
ces précisions
c'est vrai que
question du président de la commission
sont toujours un peu stimulantes non pas
pour vous ennuyer mais bien au contraire
parce qu'elle vous permettent de vous
exprimer devant la représentation
nationale
et vous savez combien vos déclarations
sont entendus sont regardés de près et
souvent que ce soit les milieux de la
presse chez les industriels ou et des
informations circulaient le mérite de
préciser c'est l'occasion qui vous est
donnée et personnellement mais je pense
exprimé le sentiment de nombre d'entre
nous autour de cette table quelles que
soient nos sensibilités nous vous
rendons tous au fromage pour la
combativité que vous mettez à nous
présenter
depuis que vous êtes au ministère des
armées un budget en conformité avec la
lpm or vous savez que le coeur de métier
de la commission de la défense du sénat
c'est de préserver strictement ni plus
ni moins les engagements de la lpm pour
lequel ensemble nous nous sommes battus
et c'est pour ça que nous sommes très
attentifs et personnellement je suis
satisfait de d'un budget de 39 milliards
2 ce qui n'allait pas de soi dans une
année où quand et dans une perspective
financière et budgétaire de 2021 qui ne
va pas être aisée alors on va y aller
plus loin maintenant avec les questions
de nos collègues qui se sont inscrits et
donc la parole on va essayer de calibrer
pour que chacun puisse parler dans le
cadre du temps que vous nous consacrer
donc la parole à cédric perrin merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs bonjour je souhaiterais
revenir sur une question qui a été posée
par le président à l'instant sur lequel
je suis désolé mais je ne suis pas
satisfait de la réponse c'est concerne
l'achat des rafale par la grèce vous
vous êtes exprimé devant l'assemblée
nationale et vous avez dit exactement ce
que vous ne nous dira l'instant donc
c'est très bien mais au-delà de ça
j'avais pris l'engagement d'en acheter
12 9 c'est ce qui est une excellente
nouvelle évidemment vous savez que vous
pouvez compter sur notre soutien le plus
total en cas de bras de fer j'allais
dire avec bercy sur le
le
le renversement j'avais au budget de la
défense du produit de la vente des
rafale aaa à la grèce mais quand même
comment
en cas de j'allais dire en cas
d'arbitrage défavorable 2,7 de ce point
comment est ce que vous envisagez de
pouvoir financer ces deux rafale parce
que c'est un point qui n'avait
évidemment pas été mis en oeuvre dans le
cadre de la programmation militaire
aussi un point important
et puis quel sera le décalage dans le
temps entre le transfert de nos
appareils vers la grèce et la livraison
par dassault de nouveaux appareils
comment est ce que vous envisagez de
combler le manque qui se fera sentir à
terme puisque vous l'avez très fort pour
tous fort justement rappelé ça
représente 10% du parc des avions de
chasse rafale de l'armée de l'air donc
c'est un point non non non négligeable
et quant aux six appareils neufs achetés
par la grèce et qu'ils seront prélevés
sur la chaîne de production des
appareils de la tranche 4 a livré à
l'armée d'ici 2024
et enfin pour terminer est ce qu'il ya
une possibilité j'imagine que vous avez
bien entendu
posez la question à l'industriel de
réduire les délais en accélérant la
production d'appareils neufs par un
industriel dassault pour ne pas le citer
sont ces questions sont évidemment
d'autant plus importante qu'elle
pourrait elle risque de se reposer
évidemment avec le contrat que nous
l'espérons de la croatie voilà je serai
pas plus leur merci beaucoup merci
cédric comme nous le faisions
précédemment je prends toutes les
questions ce qui vous permettra de faire
des réponses olivier cigolotti merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
avec mon excellent collègue gilbert
roger ici présent nous avons rédigé un
rapport sur le projet de porte avions de
nouvelle génération rapport que nous
avons présentés devant notre commission
au mois de juin et que nous avons
transmis
alors bien sûr nous ne pouvons que nous
féliciter vous féliciter de cette
trajectoire budgétaire pour ce pelleve
mais vous avez évoqué la notion de de
visibilité est ce que vous pourriez nous
donner quelques éléments complémentaires
madame la ministre sur les inscriptions
budgétaires à venir concernant le projet
de porte avions de nouvelle génération
nous avons cru comprendre quand certain
nombre de décisions et de validation de
choix technologiques devraient
intervenir dans les dents
les jours qui viennent mais pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quel pourrait être le
calendrier pour ce projet important du
porte-avions très attendu par un certain
nombre d'industriels comme l'évoquait
notre président merci madame la merci
olivier philippe hall merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
deux questions je vais revenir sur les
rafale également après ce qu'a dit le
président comment est ce qu'elle dit
cédric perrin puisque j'ai cru voir
quelque part que la croatie comptait
acheter aussi des rafales d'occasions
entre 8 et 12
donc je m'inquiète un petit peu de cette
annonce à savoir que si ça se fait ça va
être prélevé ou si c'est aussi sous le
parc de l'armée de l'air ce que si je
calcul bien donc on se retrouverait avec
12 pour la grèce plus peut-être 12
également pour la croatie ce qui ferait
24 si je calcul bien sûr 104 donc ça
fait 25 % de la capacité opérationnelle
de l'armée de l'air qui seraient
affectés
donc c'est peut-être des rumeurs mais je
voulais avoir quelques explications là
dessus et par rapport au plan de relance
j'ai vu dans le document stratégique le
document la loi de finances en page 24
les différents achats et de matériel qui
comptait être effectuées mais je voulais
vous aux intérêts interrogé un peu plus
là dessus pour savoir comment ça se
passe aux entreprises en difficulté qui
sont en lien avec les industries de
l'armement ou l'industrie d'une manière
générale dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique dont vous avez parlé de
dinars tout à l'heure tu connais un
petit peu où vous avez participé à sa
recontre d'investissement de façon à
souhait de l'emploi je vous avais envoyé
un courrier je reviens un petit peu dans
le finistère où m'excuser c'est un petit
exemple savez qu'il ya des grosses
difficultés à air france et à hope en
particulier à morlaix où il ya 276
personnes qui seront se retrouver
licenciés le prix d'angleterre france
m'a dit qu'il avait pris contact avec
vous pour recaser du personnel alors
comme je sais que il ya des recrutements
qui doivent être faits au sein des
armées en particulier du personnel civil
est ce que dans cadre du plan de relance
il est prévu quelque chose est ce que ça
peut rentrer là dedans en matière de
personnel
et puis d'autres entreprises aussi qui
sont touchés jamais une de quimper dans
le domaine de l'énergie qui a eu des
contres assez important avec le
ministère de la défense a apparemment
c'est un peu pauvre à l'heure actuelle
donc ctv juste pour savoir si dans le
cadre de ce plan il est prévu quelque
chose pour les entreprises qui sont en
difficulté qui seront peut-être un peu
en deuxième
notre deuxième siècle ce qui était prévu
jusqu'à présent puisqu'il s'agit aussi
pour nous de l'aménagement du territoire
dont il s'agit merci merci philippe à
rejeter la parole à olivier cadic mais
je voudrais prévenir uxo rickett en
visio de se préparer et donc d'ouvrir sa
caméra de telle sorte qu'on puisse le
voir à l'écran il aura la question
suivante donc maintenant olivier cadic
ainsi monsieur le président madame la
ministre
mes questions porteront sur la montée en
puissance du commandement de la cyber
défense
il y a un an vous avez inauguré le comme
cyber premier bâtiment dédié à la
conduite des opérations cyber près de
rennes
vous aviez prévu d'investir un budget de
200 millions d'euros entre 2019 et 2025
sur cette zone pour y construire le
temple de la cyber défense
deux autres bâtiments sont planifiés
d'ici à 2025
est ce que ces bâtiments sont inclus
dans le budget initial ou nécessiteront
t-il un budget supplémentaire
où en êtes-vous de la montée prévue des
effectifs en matière de cyberdéfense en
concentrant nos forces cyber à rennes
vous contribuez à faire émerger une
cyber valley européenne qui intègre des
start up de la cyber des sociétés
d'investissement des universités vous
avez dit le cyber c'est une guerre
permanente silencieuse et invisible
potentiellement dévastatrices
lorsqu'elle se montrent au grand jour
des attaques cyber ça n'arrive pas
seulement aux autres nous sommes tous
concernés
et comme son et comme nous sommes tous
concernés pour garantir notre résilience
collective
vous avez signé une convention cyber
avec les grands maîtres d'oeuvre
industriels mais vous avez voulu aller
plus loin et je m'en réjouis
vous vous êtes inquiétés des pme qui
contribuent à la défense vous avez
annoncé la création du diable cyber le
diagnostic de la cyberdéfense quel
budget est alloué à cette opération
combien de pme sont concernés par cette
opération
merci merci olivier donc hugh laurie en
vision madame le ministre merci pour
votre intervention dans notre commission
on connaît les interrogations régulière
et là des quads sur l'adéquation du
budget opex il avait des besoins dans le
budget 2021 on peut voir une évolution
lente ex or actuellement environ s'est
appréciée depuis environ 1 750 hommes
pour la plupart du gémissement le
travail extraordinaire pour relever le
port de beyrouth
compte tenu de l'ampleur de la tâche at
on une idée de la durée de leur mission
et le budget 2021 voit-il et de quelle
façon cette mission tout à la fois
exemplaire et emblématique
je vous remercie merci hugo la parole à
gilbert roger madame la ministre en
complément de mon ami olivier sur le
porte avions de nouvelle génération
une de mes interrogations lorsque nous
avons produit notre rapport
c'est un petit de danse et où
l'utilisation du charles de gaulle
pouvant
être maintenu au delà de 2038 notamment
pour garder une forme de forces
permanentes sur la méditerranée parce
que souvent hélas nous constatons que
s'il n'y a pas la france là sur ce
bassin méditerranéen
il y a personne en réalité et est ce que
vous pensez que ce soit quelque chose de
concevable sans qu'on garde l'ensemble
peut-être des attributs actuelle du
charles de gaulle tel qu'il est merci
gilbert la parole à notre nouveau
collègue ludovic haye
voilà merci monsieur crée donc mon idée
mais une fois qu'on le sait il ya aucun
problème je verrai président madame la
ministre
bonsoir chers collègues juste devrait
revenir sur le service de santé des
armées
effectivement la pandémie de l'accueil
19 a mis en exergue l'importance de
disposer d'une capacité de réaction et
de résilience à la hauteur des enjeux et
de la christ et de la criticité de la
situation ces crises sanitaires c'est
effectivement traduite ces derniers mois
par une forte mobilisation des armées au
travers d'opérations résilience comme
vous l'avez très justement indiqué et en
particulier du service de santé des
armées
comme nous avons pu le voir à mulhouse
notamment avec le déploiement de
l'élément militaire de ranimation appelé
les maires dans le jargon donc sénateurs
d'un département durement touché par la
crise sanitaire je voudrais tout d'abord
rendre hommage à l'engagement de nos
militaires à leur efficacité et à la
capacité d'adaptation tout au long de
celle-ci
je salue ici l'augmentation
substantielle du budget de services de
santé des armées qui voit son budget
augmenter de 27%
madame la ministre pourriez vous s'il
vous plaît revenir sur la transformation
intrinsèque je serais tenté de dire du
service de santé des armées et des
hôpitaux d'instruction des armées et
nous dire quels premiers enseignements
tirés de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui nous occupe encore
aujourd'hui
suite à la crainte de nombreux hôpitaux
de devoir revivre à nouveau une
situation critique
quelle est la stratégie du service de
santé des armées pour venir
ponctuellement en renfort du service
public hospitalier et l'aider à pallier
à une hypothétique pénurie de lits dans
les prochains mois après les moyens
matériels et logistiques j'aimerais
m'entretenir avec vous sur les moyens
plus humain mon département a bénéficié
de départements d'un déploiement
exceptionnel de moyens matériels
remarquable surtout de femmes et
d'hommes dévoué j'aimerais attirer votre
attention madame la ministre sur le
besoin de rendre plus attractifs les
services de santé des armées
en effet alors que les jeunes diplômés
semble se désintéresser des institutions
militaires et public au profit du privé
bien souvent plus rémunérateurs comment
pouvons nous créer des vocations dans ce
domaine
maintenir un personnel soignant
militaire hautement qualifiés et enfin
le fidéliser afin de permettre une
pérennisation de nos services de santé
merci beaucoup merci merci de vie qui
est un conte navré pour cette mauvaise
présence prononciation qui ne se
reproduira plus hélène conway mouret
merci président madame la ministre je
souhaite soulever deux points avec vous
le premier porte sur le surcoût opex et
émissions intérieur en 2019
le dépassement du budget voté a entraîné
l'annulation de 97 millions d'euros sur
le programme 146 et ce surcoût a été
également financé par le ministère de
désarmer et cela malgré l'article que
nous avions inséré dans la lpm qui fait
appel à la solidarité interministériel
donc je voudrais simplement savoir
cette année nous avons eu un
renforcement des effectifs de
l'opération barkan l'opération
sentinelle résilience donc j'aimerais
savoir à quel surcoût nous attendre
est-ce qu'il sera du même ordre que
l'année dernière c'est à dire près de 1
milliard 4 qui resterait donc
sensiblement supérieure à la provision
inscrite au budget qui est de 1,1
milliard et sur quel matériel vous quels
crédits seront impactés
pour votre ministère deuxième point vous
avez rappelé que nous sommes très
attachés et le vote de cette commission
le 15 juillet dernier a montré aussi
notre attachement au développement et à
la création du scaf et en parallèle au
mcs nous montrons beaucoup d
enthousiasme du côté français mais du
côté allemand il semblerait quand même
qu'il y ait des doutes qu'ils soient de
plus en plus exprimé par nos amis
allemands sur des avancées du mcs qui
semble pas aussi visible que pour le
scaf et comme on sait que le bundestag
au printemps dernier a voté des crédits
l'innovation en fin de développement
pour les deux programmes et qu'il allie
ils ont lié en fait les deux projets
peut se dire qu' il faudrait quand même
que le mgc s avancent aussi vite puisque
nous avons avec ronan le gleut préconisé
une accélération du projet
voilà donc où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui
est-ce que le mgc s est irréversible
pour vous et dernière question où en
sommes-nous de la consolidation et des
projets de kaïn ds dont l'avenir est
quand même intimement liés au
développement du mgc s vous remercie
merci hélène ronan le gleut merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
effectivement le 15 juillet dernier avec
ma collègue hélène conway mouret nous
rendions un rapport ce système de combat
aérien du futur et donc ma question est
relative au moyen de l'innovation parce
que en 2016 un instructeur de l'air
force jean lee n'a remporté aucune
victoire en simulation de combat aérien
contre une intelligence artificielle
alpha est sur la même idée il existe un
projet de l'air force research
laboratory pour juillet 2021 qui fera
combattre elano pas en simulation mais
en situation réelle un chasseur avec un
pilote face à un drone qui sera lui
piloté par une intelligence artificielle
éventuellement ça peut également être un
f-16 mais en tout cas il va y avoir en
juillet 2021 premier quart réel et il
ose meuse qui est le pdg de tesla et de
space x considère quant à lui qu'un
chasseur piloté par un être humain
n'aura à terme aucune chance face à un
chasseur piloté par une intelligence
artificielle
on est donc face ici ce qui probablement
est une révolution exceptionnelle et
nous sommes donc sur des travaux de
prospective longue puisque le scaf vise
à être mis en service en 2040 avec une
durée de vie de 40 ans qui nous amène à
il est donc nécessaire de faire un
véritable travail de prospective et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ma
question justement porte sur les moyens
de l'innovation les moyens de
prospective
avez vous les moyens de faire face à de
telles révolutions technologiques que ce
soit au niveau de l' agence de
l'innovation de défense ou de la red
team
je vous remercie merci renan jean louis
lagourgue
mais c'est méchant merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre ministère
des armées a mené l'opération amitié au
liban
afin de soutenir et aider nos amis
libanais suite une double explosion
meurtrière du port de beyrouth le 4 août
dernier
durant cette opération environ 750
militaires français ont été déployés
ainsi que le porte hélicoptères amphibie
tonnerre qui était au mobiliser les
multiples rotations d'avions de
transport du porte conteneurs ammann
callao affrété par le ministère des
armées ont permis l'acheminement de 1200
tonnes de fret humanitaire
madame la ministre je tiens tout d'abord
vous remercier pour cette mobilisation
qui était vital pour le liban par
ailleurs je souhaite vous interroger sur
bilan financier de cette opération calé
son coup
cette mobilisation at-elle affecté les
crédits de la mission défense 2021
est-ce que les aveugles et 7 milliards
prévus pour 2021 prendre prennent en
considération une éventuelle
mobilisation de nous armer au moyen
orient
vu l'évolution est inquiétant de la
situation régionale merci jean louis
joly mais la ministre
j'ai eu l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
de foot dire combien nous regrettions la
suspension des journée défense et
citoyenneté pour les français de
l'étranger pour raisons budgétaires
j'avais travaillé avec le général ménard
wind à ce sujet en 2018
et il a pris l'engagement de monter une
formation en ligne qui pourrait
remplacer cette idée c'est à l'étranger
dont je voudrais vous en remercier
féliciter le général ménard wind
puisqu'elle devrait être mise en place
au 1er janvier prochain
mais cela m'amène aussi à vous parler de
la réserve citoyenne à l'international
puisque le sénat a voté deux amendements
sur la loi de programme programmation
militaire 2015 2019 visant à étendre le
bénéfice de cette réserve citoyenne à
l'international il y aurait d'autres
solutions similaires par exemple dans le
cadre de l'ihd haine qui a mis en place
sa réserve et hd est né qui a mis en
place une plateforme numérique est ce
qu'il serait possible d'aller de l'avant
et quel serait le budget
et qui pourrait être apportée à ce
dossier pour que les français
d'étrangers qui sont essentiels au
maintien et au renforcement de l'esprit
de défense puisse être ramenés dans
cette communauté de défense qui ne
peuvent servir merci merci joël enfin
pierre laurent bonjour madame la
ministre
une part croissante de notre budget
militaire est consacrée aux opex ou fil
des années et je veux rebondir sur ce
que vous avez dit à propos de la
libération de ce fip et romain à propos
de l'opération barkan fait ma question
est simple c où va-t-on avec l'opération
l'arcade où vous vous répondez sur la
libération des otages est entendu ce que
vous avez dit comme si l'évolution de la
situation politique au mali d'un côté et
la poursuite de l'opération marque anne
était en quelque sorte deux chemins
parallèles qui ne sent un terreau action
l'un et l'autre évidemment tout ça n'est
pas très crédible
il ya beaucoup de questions sur
l'évolution de la situation beaucoup
d'interrogations qui préexistait déjà ce
qui vient de se passer sur la
possibilité que l'opération d'arcane
débouche sur des résultats politiques
durables pour pour la région on a plutôt
l'impression que ces interrogations
seront plus nombreuses aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était avant l'été donc où
va-t-on et est ce que le parlement va
être à nouveau saisi et quand de cette
situation pour débattre si nous devons
poursuivre ou non cette opération merci
pierre voilà madame la ministre un
cocktail de questions précises et ce
budget défense 2021
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
donc je commencerai par les questions
concernant les précisions plus
exactement concernant le programme
rafale et l'impact de la commande
grec sur le financement des deux rafale
que nous serons amenés à commander très
prochainement pour compenser l'impact
des prélèvements réalisés sur l'armé de
l'air et de l'espace
nous travaillons actuellement sur les
plans de paiements de la cinquième
tranche qui comporte comme vous le savez
30 appareils qui sont à livrer entre 27
et 30
l'objectif est d'arriver à lisser le
plus possible les impacts puisque au
fond en creuse que nous sommes en train
de nous dire c'est que cette commande
est une excellente nouvelle non
seulement pour l'entreprise dassault
mais également pour les 500 entreprises
qui contribuent au programme rafale est
en gros aux 7000 salariés qui sont
impliqués dans ce programme
donc l'objectif c'est que nous puissions
retrouver dans le cadre d'une
négociation tout à fait normal entre un
client je dirais principal est un
fournisseur que nous puissions retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre satisfaisante
donc peut-être qu'une rotation du
programme rafale sera sera nécessaire
mais en tout cas nous essaierons de
faire en sorte qu'elle soit la plus
limitée possible et en tout cas nous
apparaît soutenable en question
maintenant concernant les les
calendriers les six avions neufs
destinés à la grèce seront donc livrés
en 2022
ensuite les 28 avions de la tranche
qu'on appelle la tranche 4 t2
pardonnez-moi ccc
ces acronymes bizarre mais qui sont les
28 avions qui ont vocation à être
livrées entre la fin de l'année 22 et la
fin de l'année 24 donc on aura six
avions neuf grecs en 22 suivi des 28
avions qui sont commandés par la france
et livrables entre 22 et 24 cuisines
rond sous forme de livraison les douze
commandés très bientôt en 2025
alors pour éviter une réduction des
capacités opérationnelles intermédiaire
pour l'armée de l'air
nous travaillons également et vous le
savez mieux que personne sur la
disponibilité de la flotte actuelle
puisque les investissements
considérables sont réalisés pour le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
notamment aéronautiques avec une refonte
complète des contrats que nous avons
passé avec les industriels que nous
avons appelé contrat verticaliser pour
que la responsabilité industriels soient
clairement identifiés et nous aurons
nous attendons du contrat que nous avons
formalisé avec l'entreprise dassault qui
s'appelle le contrat ravenne en 2019
nous attendons une amélioration de la
disponibilité à hauteur de 10 appareils
en 2022 dont vous voyez on essaye de
jouer sur l'ensemble des paramètres pour
vraiment neutraliser les conséquences
d'un prélèvement réalisé sur les la
flotte de l'armée de l'air donc
je pense que bien sûr n'est pas obligé
de croire nous relèverons semble les
compteurs mais je suis assez confiante
sur le fait que ces impacts seront les
plus limitées possible aussi bien pour
l'armée de l'air que pour le budget du
ministère des armées dans la mesure où
et c'était d'ailleurs une question à
laquelle je n'ai pas répondu je crois à
ce stade
est-ce que là l'entreprise dassault et
ses sous-traitants sont capables
d'accélérer la production
eh bien il va probablement falloir oui
qu'ils accélèrent et à nouveau je
voudrais insister sur le fait qu'il y a
quelques mois
cette entreprise se faisait le porte
voix des craintes du secteur et des
craintes que l'on pouvait avoir du
ralentissement du rythme des commandes à
nouveau dans un secteur aéronautique qui
souffrent violemment de la crise
économique
et là on voit que le programme rafale
qui a été rendue exportable il ya
quelques années et je crois que ça a été
un des grands succès des années
précédentes que d'avoir donner de la
visibilité à l'exportation à cet avion
est bien ce programme rafale on devient
un outil très efficace pour les
exportations des industries d'armement
et ses industries d'armement ont besoin
à la fois des commandes de l'état mais
aussi de réussir à l'exportation dont je
suis tout à fait consciente comme
le président de l'entreprise dassault de
la nécessité désormais de se mettre en
situation de pouvoir répondre à une
demande qui est forte elle est forte
du côté de l'état français elle est
forte du côté des clients à
l'exportation a mis juste une petite
précision pour qu'on soit bien clair sur
ce point budgétaire est ce que vous
voulez dire que le produit de la vente
des rafale à la grèce sera réaffecté au
budget des armées de thé sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de difficultés le moment venu a
racheté les fameux avion que vous aller
commander ou bien est-ce que ça tombe
dans le budget général et qu'il faudra
de nouveau se battre pour libérer en
quelque sorte les crédits nécessaires
pour qu'on soit bien coeur monsieur le
président la 'règle budgétaire' je crois
est clair lorsqu'il ya une session de ce
type
le produit de la cession revient au
budget général il faudra donc que nous
menions le combat afin que le ce produit
de cette cession soit compensée au
ministère des armées
c'est tout à fait clair il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté de il ne peut pas
y avoir d'ambiguïté là-dessus et la
règle n'a pas été modifié bon mais nous
le savons tous et bien sûr nous nous
nous serons en sorte panon ferons nos
meilleurs efforts pour que ceux ci ne
soient pas comment dire retenues contre
le budget du ministère des armées
j'en viens maintenant mais nous aurons
j'imagine loin
moult occasions d'y revenir
ultérieurement dans les prochains jours
j'en viens maintenant aux porte avions
de nouvelle génération et je vais
répondre si vous voulez bien ensemble
aux deux sénateurs qui sont à l'origine
de ce rapport
excellent concernant cet outil
fondamental pour notre autonomie
stratégique alors s'agissant d'abord des
études et de la d inscription budgétaire
correspondant à ce projet peut être
avant cela devrait vous dire que nous
avons travaillé depuis la fin de l'année
2008 sur différentes options sur
différents schémas ne comptez pas sur
moi pour vous en révéler plus que cela
puisque ce sont des arbitrages qui ont
vocation à être rendus et annoncer très
prochainement
néanmoins ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'en 2021 260 millions deux cent
soixante et un pour être précis millions
d'euros seront engagés pour poursuivre
les études du porte avions de nouvelle
génération et nous savons
depuis le début car nous en avions parlé
lors du débat sur la loi de
programmation militaire que l'essentiel
des crédits liés à la réalisation sont
en fait ne concerne pas cette loi de
programmation militaire mais très
probablement la prochaine et la suivante
donc l'objectif c'est que nous puissions
disposer d'un porte avions de nouvelle
génération sus opérationnel en 2038
et c'est pour cela que les décisions
doivent être annoncés sans tarder pour
que nous puissions poursuivre les études
que nous avons amorcé alors j'en viens à
la question plus précise sur la durée de
vie de l'actuel un porte avions charles
de gaulle
aujourd'hui il ne m'est pas possible de
répondre à la question que s'est arrogé
se pose parce que nous avons besoin
d'abord d'avoir refait un arrêt
technique majeur et probablement nous
aurons d'ici sept ou huit ans donc lors
du prochain arrêt technique majeur prévu
pour le porte avions charles de gaulle
nous aurons une meilleure idée de du
potentiel résiduel que ce navire dans ce
navire disposera donc il est habituel de
se poser la question de la prolongation
au-delà du terme si je puis dire
officiel
d'un équipement qu'il soit bateau qu'il
s'agisse d'avion donc nous nous
reposerons naturellement cette question
mais aujourd'hui je ne peux pas y
répondre de façon de ça de façon
documentée questions sur la situation
des ateliers de maintenance de up air
france basée à morlaix
l'entreprise air france a annoncé
qu'elle allait engager un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi concernant ces
ateliers de maintenance à l'échéance de
la direction d'air france s'est
rapprochée du ministère des armées pour
commencer d'examiner les possibilités de
reclassement d'un certain nombre de
salariés d'europe sur le bassin d'emploi
de morlaix les services de recrutement
du ministère sont parfaitement
sensibilisés à cette question et donc
sont tout à fait disposés à examiner les
candidatures de ceux qui souhaiteraient
la présenter pour intégrer le ministère
des armées
donc c'est un processus qui n'en est
qu'à ses débuts et donc nous allons
examiner avec beaucoup de sérieux les
éventuelles candidatures qui nous serait
présenté je n'ai pas connaissance je
vous prie de m'en excuser monsieur le
sénateur de l'entreprise de quimper que
vous avez mentionné ce que je peux dire
et redire à chacun d'entre vous sait que
cette équipe de la dg a et a été créé
pour précisément permettre de répondre à
toutes les difficultés éventuelles qui
se manifeste donc surtout dans vos
circonscriptions sur votre territoire
faites savoir aux entreprises concernées
que nous sommes à leur disposition et
naturellement vous pouvez m'écrire ou
saisir les membres de mon cabinet c'est
la raison d'être de cette équipe et nous
sommes là pour tenter de répondre du
mieux possible aux difficultés
éventuelles qu'elle pourrait traverser
donc surtout qu'elle ne tarde pas à se
manifester
on sait bien que c'est lorsque l'on dit
faire comme on dit à la sollicitation de
différentes aides qu'on peut
éventuellement aggraver les problèmes
auxquels on est confrontés questions sur
leur temps et je suis un peu perdu alors
j'ai fait pas répondre dans l'ordre je
reviendrai aux questions que je n'ai pas
traité ultérieurement
donc question sur le com cyber donc en
effet
j'ai rappelé lorsque je me suis rendu à
deux reprises à rennes y compris et très
récemment les engagements que nous avons
pris dans le cadre de la lpm qui sont à
la fois des engagements en terme
d'effectif puisque nous avons prévu de
recruter 1000 cyber combattants
supplémentaires sur la période de la lpm
pourrait très précis 1106 bercloux
battant sur la période 2010 9 2025 et
nous avons également
planifier la réalisation d'un certain
nombre d'infrastructures lune que j'ai
inauguré en 2019 et deux autres
bâtiments dont la construction est
programmé pour y accueillir les cyber
combattants qui seront recrutés d'ici
2025 donc s'agissant du dispositif que
j'ai annoncé qu'ils s'appellent diack
cyber qui part du constat que au fond
nous avons besoin d'une cyber sécurité
de bout en bout et que nous voyons bien
que non seulement nos propres systèmes
je parle de ceux du mystère d armée sont
la cible régulière d'attaqués et d'attac
en nombre croissant
mais nous voyons aussi qu'au fur et à
mesure que nous renforçons nos propres
défenses pour protéger nos systèmes
souverain les hackers se dirigent de
façon préférentielle vers ce qu'ils
imaginent être le maillon faible en
quelque sorte c'est à dire
potentiellement les industriels et leurs
systèmes leur système d'information donc
c'est pour cela que nous avons décidé de
mettre en place ce dispositif diack
cyber destiné en particulier aux pme qui
sont les moins outillée par construction
pour faire face à cela et nous avons
décidé décidé d'y allouer 4 millions et
demi
l'objectif est de prendre en charge 50 %
des dépenses engagées par les pme pour
remettre à niveau leurs systèmes de
l'information et les protéger contre les
attaques cyber ceci dans un plafond de
14000 euros hors taxes
et je ne suis pas en mesure de vous dire
aujourd'hui
et on pourra vous fournir bien sûr tous
les éléments sur les entreprises qui
auraient déjà bénéficié de ce dispositif
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'elles ont accueilli l'annoncé
de ce mécanisme avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt et de satisfaction questions
sur l'opération amitié je crois que vous
avez été 2 aam la poser tout d'abord je
vous remercie pour les propos que vous
avez vu pour nos militaires qui ont été
engagés dans cette opération et je
m'efforcerai de les leur répercuter en
ce qui concerne le coût de cette mission
il est estimé à ce stade à 8 millions
d'euros en tout cas pour ce que nous
avons réalisés à compter du mois d'août
donc comme vous le voyez ce ne sont pas
des montants qui sont susceptibles
d'affecter en profondeur le comment dire
le niveau des surcoûts opex dont je
rappelle que c'est une provision qu'une
provision
ne peut pas être exact sinon ce ne
serait pas une provision mais une
inscription définitive et que je ne suis
gentil sip sur la réponse à la question
de la sénatrice conway je ne suis pas en
mesure aujourd'hui de vous dire quel
sera le montant définitif du coût des
opérations des opex et des opérations de
l'opération sentinelle et résilience car
l'année 2020 n'est pas terminée
ce que nous savons c'est que nous avons
à la fois des facteurs à majorant et des
facteurs minorant des facteur majorant
puisque s'agissant en opération barkan
celle ci a été rehaussé de 500 effectif
depuis le début de l'année nous avons
des facteurs minorant par exemple le
fait que nous utilisons beaucoup moins
de munitions dans le cadre de
l'opération au levant l'opération shamal
puisque nous utilisons moins de
munitions et les les
les avions qui sont bazin jordan est
désormais sont essentiellement des
opérations de reconnaissance des seuils
de surveillance donc c'est la somme de
ses effets si je puis dire qu'il
produira le montant définitif des
déchets copex mais nous savons que nous
avons une provision maintenant qui est
importante puisqu'elle a été
progressivement relevé et qu'elle est a
été porté l'année dernière à 1 milliard
en fait 200 millions d'euros si on
inclut la masse salariale qui concerne
les opérations intérieures donc
vous dirais volontiers rendez vous dans
quelques semaines lorsque nous
examinerons ensemble le projet de loi de
finances rectificative et que nous
verrons dans quelle condition à la fois
quel est le montant du surcoût
prévisionnel et quel est son financement
donc il est il est trop tôt pour
répondre à cette question
j'en viens maintenant au service de
santé des armées
et je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
de l'aude et des propos très très
positif que vous avez eue envers les
personnels du service de santé des
armées qui en effet n'ont pas compté
leur temps ni leur coeur dans les
opérations qui l'ont conduite pendant la
première vague de la crise en
particulier dans le grand est
j'ai été amené à m'exprimer sur le
le futur du service de santé des armées
il ya quelques jours d'abord pour
rappeler que c'est un service qui comme
beaucoup d'autres au sein de notre
ministère a été conduit à mener des
restructurations extrêmement importante
importante et exigeante et je crois
maintenant que nous sommes arrivés au
terme de ce plan de transformation et
que nous avons pu en tirer les
enseignements notamment à l'aune des
événements que nous avons vécu en ce
printemps 2020 donc personnellement je
n'ai pas attendu la crise sanitaire pour
prendre une première décision
conservatoire qui a consisté à stopper
les dépressions d'effectif car en
réalité le plan ss à 2020 devait aller
plus loin et dès 2017 avec geneviève
darrieussecq nous avons décidé d'arrêter
ses déflation d'effectifs et nous avons
commencé de remonter le niveau des
effectifs du service de santé des armées
par ailleurs nous avions décidé de
prendre deux premières mesures de
revalorisation salariale consciente que
comme vous de la nécessité de d'avoir un
service de santé des armées attractif
pour les praticiens et les personnels
médicaux nous avons donc consacré au
cours des années 17 à 20 31 millions
d'euros aux revalorisations salariales
pour le service de santé des armées
mais au-delà de tout cela il me paraît
important désormais de tracé
une feuille de route pour ce service et
de la trace est en pleine adéquation
avec l'ambition que nous nous sommes
fixés pour nos armées à l'horizon 2030
et donc faire coïncider au fond la
feuille de route du service de santé des
armées avec celles qui figurent dans la
loi de programmation militaire afin que
le ss ça serve ce modèle d'armée complet
dont nous sur lequel nous sommes tombés
d'accord
donc cette feuille de route elle vise
d'abord à réaffirmer au fond la finalité
de ce service est je le rappelle il
s'agit de répondre aux besoins médicaux
de nos forces
je le dis de manière assez solennel et
ça ne signifie nullement que le service
de santé des armées ne participerait pas
à nouveau si je puis dire à la gestion
nationale d'une deuxième vague
épidémique mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est un service dont la
mission est de permettre à nos forces de
se déployer de combattre avec
l'assurance que des médecins des
infirmiers des auxiliaires médicaux sont
auprès d'eux au plus près de la ligne de
front pour les soigner et les
les les traiter donc je souhaite dans ce
cadre redéfinir la relation du service
de santé des armées avec le système de
santé publique
encore une fois essayé de se soustraire
à notre contribution mais c'est une
contribution qui ne peut intervenir qu'à
la hauteur des moyens qui sont les
nôtres et donc le service de santé des
armées est complémentaire du service
santé publique mais il ne peut pas se
substituer au système de santé public
c'est évident la disproportion des des
échelles et est trop et trop grande
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
confirmé le choix en faveur de deux
grandes plateformes hospitalières
militaire l'une au nord constitué des
deux hôpitaux de persil et de béja et
l'une au sud constituée des hôpitaux
laveran à marseille et sainte anne à
toulon j'ai été amené également à dire
que nous continuerions d'investir
au profit de ces hôpitaux et j'ai
précisé que à brest où nous avons un
hôpital qui s'appelle clermont tonnerre
et bien cet hôpital sera lui même
renforcé pour pouvoir faire face aux
besoins très spécifiques de nos marins
et en particulier de tous ceux qui
participent à la force océanique
alors il reste un certain nombre de
documents qui ont déjà commencé leur
rapprochement avec le système de santé
publique
et là je souhaite que nous réengager une
discussion avec les partenaires locaux
il y a eu des changements importants à
la tête de ces grandes villes je veux
parler de lyon de bordeaux metz et donc
je souhaite que nous poursuivions les
transformations en lien étroit avec les
territoires de santé et en étant
attentif à ce que les projets répondent
à la satisfaction du besoin des armées
et enfin je terminerai en disant que
l'expérience de la crise sanitaire nous
a montré qu' il y a une forte
complémentarité entre la médecine
hospitalière et la médecine des forces
qu'il nous faut donc travailler à
nouveau à les rapprocher en tout cas
leur permettre de mieux travailler
ensemble
voilà grosso modo les les grandes lignes
de ce de ce cette feuille de route qui
se va se traduire également par un
effort en matière de d'effectif puisque
nous allons revoir à hauteur de 100
emplois au delà de ce que la lpm avait
ouvert au profit du sssa afin
d'augmenter de 15% le nombre d'élèves
praticiens en formation
nos écoles et 160 millions d'euros
viendront compléter les ressources
programmés dans la lpm à la fois pour
réinvestir dans le ravitaillement
sanitaire ça c'est indispensable compte
tenu de ce que nous avons vécu le
prélèvement sur les stock qui a pu être
réalisée au cours de ces derniers mois
il faut donc les reconstituer je veux
dire budgétairement parce que la
reconstitution a évidemment commencer
nous n'avons pas attendu mais il faut
aussi améliorer notre réponse aux
risques biologiques
il nous faut faire un effort pour
remettre à niveau la numérisation du
système de santé des armées
et puis mon pouvoir financer des
développements capacitaire donc dès 2021
ce sont 28 millions d'euros qui seront
mobilisés à l'intérieur du budget
dans cette enveloppe de 160 millions
d'euros qui a été dégagé
dans le cadre de l'ale thème pour mieux
répondre à la remontée en puissance du
sssa voilà pardon d'avoir été un peu
long mais je crois que le sujet ne
méritez vous il y avait porté une très
grande attention dans vos travaux
[Musique]
alors questions concernant le lait
programme en coopération avec
l'allemagne
le scaf et le mgc s
alors pour ce qui concerne j'essaie de
les garer mais c'est pas grave
donc ce sont des programmes qui sont
tout à fait quand j'ai égaré mon tapis
mais c'est pas grave ce sont des
programmes qui sont très actifs donc
c'est vrai que le système de combat
aérien du futur a été rendue très
visible au cours des derniers mois
puisque nous avons été amenés à signer
des accords puis à lancer des études qui
doivent permettre la livraison de ce
démonstrateur en 2026 il en va de même
pour le char de combat du futur puisque
cette en pleine crise kobe tout sans
doute une moindre visibilité que nous
avons avec ma collègue allemande signé
le premier accord en permettant le
lancement du projet chars de combat du
futur il s'agit de l'accord cadre de
coopération qui concerne la phase de
construction du démonstrateur du projet
m gcs et l'allemagne a notifié en mai
2020 le premier contrat correspondant
donc nous sommes si je puis dire en
cours
alors c'est vrai que
il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
accomplir c'est vrai qu'il y a une forte
attention de la partie allemande à au
bon avancement du projet de chars de
combat du futur afin que celui ci
progresse à un rythme comparable si ce
n'est strictement aligné à celui du
système de combat et un du futur et nous
y veillons l'entreprise kahn dsk
vocation à jouer un rôle important au
sein de ceux de ce programme
d'équipement et donc nous travaillons à
ce que les industriels du secteur en
particulier gamme ds ils prennent toute
leur part j'en viens maintenant à la
question concernant l'intelligence
artificielle et les capacités
considérables que ces technologies vont
apporter
je voudrais dire que
nous sommes au ministère des armées très
investi sur ces questions d'intelligence
artificielle dans une double approche à
la fois se donner les moyens à travers
l'innovation l' agence de l'innovation
de défense et les investissements prévus
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire pour ne pas prendre de retard
dans ces domaines technologie et c'est
vrai que la prise en compte de
l'intelligence artificielle dans les
systèmes d'armes est un enjeu majeur
mais c'est aussi un enjeu majeur je peux
le lire sur le plan de l'éthique et
c'est pour cette raison que j'étais
amené à créer un comité ministériel des
tic dont la justification première était
de nous aider à appréhender la prise en
compte de l'intelligence artificielle
dans l'ensemble de nos systèmes et les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
mais plus largement pour nous aider à
penser les usages des armes du futur
notamment de la robotisation d'un
certain nombre de systèmes d'armes
ce comité a été installé il a commencé
de travailler et il vient de me rendre
un premier rapport est donc je pense que
vous en aurez communication très
rapidement parce que ces rapports ont
vocation à être partagé et
n'ont pas vocation à simplement inspiré
le ministère des armées mais a contribué
à nourrir ce débat qui est un débat
nécessaire qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne
peut pas éluder questions concernant le
la jdc je crois madame la sénatrice que
vous y aviez rappeler la réponse que
j'avais été amené e à vous faire un
mystère des armées n'est pas le
financeur de la jdc en dehors du
territoire national
est ce que la réserve citoyenne et
mobilisables je prends note de la
question je ne peux pas répondre comme
cela sur le siège donc je jure que je
vais regarder ce qu'il en est question
concernant
la part du budget consacré aux opex
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur de
rappeler que nous avons consacré au
cours des années récentes
une part croissante de ce budget aux
opex puisque c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons élevé le niveau de
la provision
je ne suis pas certaine que
en 2020 il y aura une croissance très
visible de ceux de ce budget est en tout
cas la provision n'a pas vocation à
croître en 2021
parce que nous avons fait l'hypothèse
que nous avions redouter la provision à
un niveau qui nous paraissaient à
l'époque cohérent avec l'estimation que
nous pouvons en faire de ces deux cd
pense naturellement tout ceci peut être
invalidé en cas de modification de nos
déploiements et du contexte
international je suis la première à
l'admettre je ne sais pas monsieur le
président si c'est le moment de revenir
très largement sur l'opération barkan
nous devrons eu l'occasion de le faire
je sais que votre commission
[Musique]
parfois me sollicite pour consacrer une
audition tout entière à ces questions
d'une très grande importance donc
j'hésite à me lancer et jeu tout en
indiquant que je reste évidemment à
votre entière disposition pour être
entendu sur cette question très très
importante
quelle est l'évolution de la situation
au sahel et de notre engagement
je pense panama midi on peut peut-être
réserver cette partie de réponse au
débat dont nous avons toujours
l'intention d'en organiser le la tenue
avec on devait le faire au printemps on
n'a pas pu le faire pour les raisons que
tout le monde connaît mais je pense que
l'opération barkan pause suffisamment de
questions ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure et je regardais des dépêches qui
tombe et qui montrait l'accueil
triomphal que magali le le terroriste le
plus recherché par la france a organisé
autour des prisonniers libérés ça fait
un peu froid dans le dos et j'imagine
que nos soldats ce soir à gao ne sont
pas très rassurée par tout ça donc je
pense que et bien évidemment nous
prenons avec de vos explications qui
sont durs et celles qui sont rapportés
par différents experts à savoir que la
france n'a pas été partie prenante dans
cette libération
bon alors il souhaitait y est sûrement
qu'elle soit mais je pense que le sujet
est trop important et je leur envoie à
l'organisation d'un débat que l'on va
essayer de mettre de mettre sur pied
mais je voulais vous faire part de la
sensibilité de l'émotion que cette
affaire créée pour la commission de la
défense
parce que je rappelle souvent y compris
dans les débats que nous avons que les
parlementaires votent l'envoi enfin en
tous les cas dans la le vote des cas
après les quatre premiers mois il ya un
vote du parlement donc on est quelque
part quand même responsable de la
sécurité de ces femmes et de ces hommes
est donc savoir qu' une partie de ces
gens qui sont des terroristes avérés
sont de nouveau en liberté est récupérée
triomphalement par monsieur la galice
sonne sonne
nous rassure pas merci en tous les cas
je vous avez peut-être d'autres non vous
n'avez pas d'autres sujets sur lequel
vous souhaitez intervenir le président
répondre à dallas et d'attrition
guillaume naud puisque toujours répondre
le petit papier est revenu donc
s'agissant de la réserve citoyenne qui
est donc un dispositif qui dessinent et
à renforcer l'esprit de défense et
renforcer le lien armée nation et
français de l'étranger ont toute
légitimité pour rejoindre cette réserve
qui est bénévole
alors il faut que nous puissions
faciliter leur engagement c'est le rôle
aussi de nos attachés de défense et donc
nous y travaillons et la ministre
déléguée veillera à donner un contenu
concret à cette intention voilà pour
cette audition de florence parly la
ministre des armées est très largement
revenu sur la libération de ce fip et
ronin l'ex otage détenu par des
djihadistes au mali et selon florence
parly la décision de relâcher des
djihadistes en échange est une décision
qui a été prise par les autorités
maliennes voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci nous avoir suivis restez
avec plus d'information politique et
parlementaire continue son
nous